e
e e
during the hearing on Senate Bill
485 and um
it adds a it does
um three things number f it does three
things number one it um adds a
definition for digitally variable
license
and it adds
um an an amends uh RSA 332 D3 G col 7 to
um to uh specify or to um put into
statute military training Education
Service acceptable for each military
occupational
specialty and also there's a new
paragraph that we had a conversation
about not only oplc boards but non oplc
boards and it amends RSA
332 DG col 7 by saying every board or
commission under this title shall
complete the rule making requirements in
paragraph
4 so I think these are the three things
that we had talked about for the
amendment and does anybody have any
comments or
questions it's I think it's simple it's
nice and simple good
yeah
okay does anybody want to make a motion
to adopt the
amendment okay and I'll second that all
those in
favor okay 3 to
zero and then would our um
would
then would we then recommend otpa to the
committee do you want to make that
motion representative Smith do you want
a second okay all those in favor I
okay anyone
opposed nope all right then I think that
we have concluded the work that we need
to do for the s
committee thank you does anybody have
any comments
or well if you want yes I guess we're
we've we am ending the hearing on the
subcommittee thank
you
e
e e
you do today great if not we'll do them
Tuesday on Wednesday we have a hearing
for the last three Senate bills and
after that it's only subcommittee work
until uh until the end of the the
Senate 11 I'd like to have a caucus
before the which is why I made it start
so late
yeah every time I schedule it like for
10:30 somebody schedules a subcommittee
for
10 session was canceled for next week
yep more time for subcommittee work
or
whatever just saying I might need
[Laughter]
it good point
even
[Laughter]
worse
e
e e
all right good
afternoon for the committee's
edification three of the bills we're
hearing today are early bills and will
need to be voted out of
committee no later than next
week my plan is to start an exec on all
three of them and if we need to recess
it until next week to get an amendment
or have a work session or something
we'll do so but we need to for
scheduling purposes we need to at least
start the exact on Senate Bill
134 480 and 487 because those are the
early
bills all right so starting with Senate
Bill
134 I called Senator
birdell thank you madam chair thank you
committee um for the record my name is
uh Regina burzell on state senator for
district 19 which encompasses the towns
of dairy Hamstead in Windham and I am
the prime sponsor of Senate Bill 134 and
I apologize for it being so long Inc
coming but we had um a lot of work to do
on it um this started out in 2022 I was
pres it was presented to me um from one
of my PTSD commission members had asked
me to look into it so I went ahead and I
put in 134 and what it you'll be hearing
from the two off officers that it's uh
basically going to be impacting but um
it's it designs a new uh retirement and
I worked very closely with Marty Carlin
um and this is a new provision for
retirements um a new provision for
violent accidental
disability excuse
me and or death retirement
benefits um it contained ambiguous
provisions and inconsistencies with
current law which could have hindered
proper implementation of the bill is
which is why I went ahead um it was
presented in J
January and um a amendment was presented
in January and I took a look at it it I
didn't think it did what we wanted to do
so Marty Carlin myself and oh speak of
the devil Marty Carlin myself um worked
on this um throughout so um meetings
with members of the New Hampshire
retirement system produced significant
Chang es to Senate Bill 134
including excuse me strengthening the
definition of purposeful hostile and
violent act removing the cola benefit
keeping the Survivor benefit the same as
existing group two um benefits and
revising The Med medical subsidy and
requiring medical
reexamination um this went through the
Senate finance committee I believe last
week and um we brought it to the floor
last Thursday and that is why you have
it right here um and I do I can have my
admin send you a listing I have a um
Marty was really good about putting
together I had asked him to put together
a comparison sheet one with the uh
current group two job related what 134
initially wanted and then what we
finally came up with so I can have um my
admin send it to the chair and she can
get it out to Youk we we definitely want
the comparison of what 134 as it
currently exists versus the basic uh
retirement benefits yep we're not really
too worried about what you fixed in the
Senate because we we don't need to worry
about it if you took care of it there
might there might be some tweaks that me
we might have to make with it but other
than that I think uh we can do that
pretty
quickly okay you're on no times
constraint I know yes thank you are
there any questions representative leus
and then representative Schmid thank you
this is um concerning the fiscal note um
I'm wondering if the dollar amounts
reflect the final bill that came out of
the Senate I noticed there are things in
here which don't like the methodology
still list the cola correct that is
actually why I started working on it
because it was such a um high price tag
so that's why I worked with it I don't
we don't have a current um fiscal note
on
it okay representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so good
afternoon Senator is this uh Bill
brought at the request of any particular
group it was brought as a request from
um the two police officers that uh were
in affected and anyone in the future
that's affected by a violent act um with
a deadly weapon thank you
questions all right thank you very much
Senator yes I'd like to hear from Mr
Carlin on definition of what this is
actually
doing excellent thank you very much
thank you madam chair while those are
making their way around I'll introduce
myself um Marty Carlin representing the
New Hampshire retirement system uh nhrs
doesn't have a position on this bill
either way it's it's a policy decision
for the
legislature does everybody have a
handout now
um so as um as Senator berzel stated
when she introduced the bill uh this was
a bill from last year that was retained
in the Senate R retained in committee
and um amended on uh the opening day of
the session uh we still had um several
Technical and mechanical concerns with
that bill as as amended uh and I reached
out to Senator berzel um and we've had
several conversations over the months
about trying to uh get something that
met the intention of the of the the bill
uh and it was also able for nhrs to
administer it
effectively um so the
handout that I gave you was a side by
side um of the current group two job
related disability benefit which is
referred to as accidental disability in
the statute um the Senate Bill 134
doesn't replace that rather it creates a
third level of disability for group to
only uh you know the violent attack uh
violent accidental disability do you
mean that someone who qualifies under
this new benefit is also eligible to the
regular disability benefit it they not
both it would it would be neither or
it's like there there's a lot of people
who are injured on the job but you know
their their injury was accidental or not
a violent intent or things like that
where they would still qualify under
this this this carves out a a what what
um the expectation is is a very small
niche of people you know who were you
know you know shot chasing someone uh
you know things like that or you know
just just you know violent attacks um
that prevent them from going forward as
opposed to you know a car crash you know
where it was there was no intent it was
an accident but they still aren't aable
to work that the existing disability
benefit would be would remain so it' be
three
three levels of
disability and for act for job related
disability in group one and group two uh
basically this can happen to as long as
it's a work rated injury um you know you
can qualify for this at any point in
your career somebody early on in their
career could be injured or or a veteran
um many years in um the current
disability benefit has a um you know
there's a definition accident repeated
trauma gradual degradation while on the
job or job related occupational disease
um typically we look to the Department
of Labor uh for determination on whether
on the work relatedness piece uh for for
that and if if the qualifications are
met in the
independent Med medical examiner finds
that the the disability is likely to be
permanent and would prevent them from
doing that job going forward they're
they're granted a benefit um the new
bill has a a more strict and limited um
definition um someone who has been
totally and permanently incapacitated
for Duty as the result of a purposeful
hostile and violent attack upon such
member in the line of duty uh in this
section the definition of purposeful
hostile and violent attack means a
physical attack with a deadly weapon as
defined in RSA
62515 done with conscious intent and
with such force that it results in the
infliction of serious bodily injury as
defined in RSA 625 1116 that's a
criminal statute um defining uh you know
assault with a deadly weapon so that
that's that's where the reference was
there um that was in the original
amended version of the bill but that
that left sort of a gap as you know nhrs
it's boor its staff aren't qualified
investigators um you know to look at a
situation like that and make a
determination whether the the definition
was met um so um Senator berzel reached
out we we had original only thought
maybe the AG's office would be the
appropriate body they um um didn't feel
it was in their wheelhouse and um the
commissioner of safety however um was
open for being the the person who would
review the um the record and and make
that certification to the board so they
could move forward with this benefit the
commissioner and the staff over at
safety already do this for that $100,000
line of duty death benefit um that's not
in our statute but um as well as for
issues with Troopers injured on the job
and whether they're have to use their
sick time or not depending on the nature
so there's a sort of a structure and a
process and an actual actually a statute
governing how that is done over there so
um the attorney from safety provided
that language to us which we provided to
Senator bird cell so we have a we have a
clearer definition than we did we have a
qualified body making that determination
um
and um so so we feel it's it's
administer at this
point
um there um so what happens if someone
qualifies for this and they they meet
the medical criteria as well um the
benefit is going to be a little
different than the current accidental
disability benefit for group two uh
which is 66 and 23 of their average
final compensation whether that's a high
three or a high five um that's that's
the um and there's also because it's a
set amount if the person who is
injured has more years of service so
that their service retirement would have
a larger percentage of their ASC there's
a supplemental benefit to make them
whole for anything above 66 and 23 that
66 and 2/3 is a a taxfree benefit
because it's a a job related disability
um the supplemental is not so that's the
current
law the change in this um senet Bill 134
it's 100% % of the member's annual rate
of earnable compensation so whatever
their salary was in the last 12 months
would be the benefit amount or
$75,000 whichever is greater so it
creates a floor benefit um
for the uh you know for for this
particular benefit so that that that's
the benefit
structure do you want me to keep going
or do you want to take questions on that
or U let's see if there are questions
representative Shu has a question
thank you madam chair thank you Mr
Carlin uh good afternoon um I assume
that you have numbers of the amount of
people who are currently uh receiving
benefits Under The
Accidental portion can you share with us
how many that would be and do you have
any kind of an estimate how many might
of those might apply under the other um
there there is approximately between 400
450 accidental group two disability
recipients currently um without without
having looking back into the files and
looking at the The Narrative of their
cases it's hard to say um how many would
have qualified th this bill does in
section two contain session law though
that it's a look back for anyone who
retired under group two accidental
disability on or after 7 one of 18 can
come back and apply for this still go
through the certification process um
that's not a magic date um there may be
some people who may have been injured
before that or not um you know there's
you know there's a few uh actually had
spoken to a couple of folks who are you
know have are retired under these
circumstances Googling I thought of a
couple of other high-profile things that
were stuck in my mind and and so you
know there's there's probably you know
more than there's at least two and more
than x um you know but the look back
right now in this in the bill is till um
71 of 18 so that's a retroactive
application it wouldn't be the benefit
wouldn't be retroactive to the date it
would be start with the with the grant
of the new level of
disability other questions
represent no represent LE thank you um
so so for the uh the new benefit says
that it would be 100% or or 75,000 but
says it would be taxfree it can it be if
it's 100% under the federal yeah um it
yeah I I I think I think there was a
dollar limit or something with with
taxability of of debility benefits but
these
these my understanding from our lawyers
is that that it would all be a taxfree
benefit okay thank you and well followup
followup
um I know in the original or the the
fiscal note we have has a fairly
substantial
cost um I don't know to what extent the
Chang in the bill modified that but is
there some idea of what the change in
the fiscal note would be yeah it's going
to be significantly less than that
number I I I looked at when I printed
out the bill this morning I looked at
the fiscal note and because of the way
the amendment was drafted it it
was fairly open-ended so the ACT assumed
essentially that half the population who
retire on disability would get this
benefit and that you know with with this
definition that that's a much more
narrower uh group than than 50% you know
I couldn't put a percentage on it but I
mean this this is you know these events
happen you know not
often you know these limited attack
events so so that fiscal note def you
know um is is irrelevant to the current
bill that the Senate amended and sent
over one more followup one more followup
um okay I didn't see anything in here
funding this so is it am I correct in
assuming this is going to increase the
uh uh unfunded liability it again if if
you know the the stated intent um over
in the Senate and the the definition we
believe it's going to be a very limited
number of people who would receive this
benefit to the extent that those folks
are getting more under this benefit than
they are under the current accidental
disability benefit that would obviously
increase costs um you know for funding
the plan it depending on the number of
people who qualify it it may or may not
show up in the rates you know it may be
in the rounding and it there's a cost
but it's it's uh di Minimus enough where
it wouldn't be obvious um we don't you
know you know so that and that would um
kind of show up over time with
experience as you know that this has
been on the books for a few years years
we see how many people are getting it
the ACT will have some data to make a
projection going forward for future
rates okay thank
you there would be no unfunded piece um
it it would just be a normal cost
increase I I believe
yeah thank you madam chair um yeah just
looking on the second to last page of
the fiscal note there um where it said
the New Hampshire retirement system
actuary projects an increase to the actu
acud liability of 87.6 million you're
saying that would be if 50% of the
people were receiving the
benefit yeah and I I I know that it's
not going to be that much in this but
that's that's what it was based off of
yes and I I I think the or the version
who never saw the the previously amended
version I think it was a it was a look
back to everyone who was retired as well
so that's that's where the unfunded
piece would have come in on that um you
know you know honestly that you know it
had enough drafting issues where it was
really hard for them to Val so they went
very conservative on it um because
because of the ambiguities in the bill
okay thank you thank you other
questions I have one
um still looking at the fiscal note
there's a whole lot of issues with the
with the language and the interpretation
have those been resolved yes we we um
yeah we we this the version you have in
front of you we we've reviewed as has um
folks in the risk management unit and
admin services and safety and and nobody
had any um obvious concerns with with
the the amended version that the Senate
passed last week
okay um so if you flip the page um
there's a couple of other boxes on the
back uh the you know the the eligibility
and the benefit uh levels are larger
there's also um gainful occupation which
is the top row on the second page that's
a provision in the law right now where
if someone is receiving a disability
Group one or group to job related or
non-job related there are limits on how
much income they can earn in retirement
without offsetting their disability
benefit you know so there's a there's a
formula involved in that um for current
group two accidental disability uh once
the person turns 45 and would have had
20 years of service there's no more
gainful occupation for this new level
there would be no gainful occupation at
all so the person could get the violent
accidental disability benefit and if
they were able to work in a another
capacity and and you know be compensated
for that it wouldn't offset their their
disability benefit from nhrs isn't that
a isn't that an issue with with the
taxability of it well they're their
income from other employment would be
taxable and I I I don't I I will bring
that back to our um to our legal folks
because that didn't come up in our
internal discussions and and one of them
is a former tax attorney so and it's
always a but I still want to double
checking for you okay
um and then the the last piece is
medical subsidy I'm not sure some of you
who have been around a few years may be
familiar with that term this is a a
benefit that the legislature created in
the late 80s and early 90s for the
different groups and have been phasing
it out over time this is a payment
um if if a retiree is receiving
insurance through their former employer
uh and HRS will pay a set amount in
statute to offset any out- of- pocket
premiums they're paying to the former
employer whether it's a political
subdivision or school or the state um
the plan is closed to group one members
now um group two members who were in
service um on June 30th of 2000 and
they're still working they'll be subsidy
eligible when they retire as Will Group
gr two regular current accidental
disability retirements who were active
before July 1 of 2005 so this you know
and that that's a ever shrinking pool um
you know as as we get farther away from
those dates this uh bill would create a
subsidy for these this category of
disability um you know with uh for with
a a larger monthly premium offset amount
$1,000 per person prior to medic care
eligibility and 630 and change after
that that percentage is the same as the
percentage in the current subsidy
amounts for those who are receiving it
but it's just a larger Base number and
again if their if their insurance
premiums that they were paying from
their former employer were less than
that they wouldn't get the extra we
would pay up to the amount and if the
amount was greater they'd pay pay the
difference um so that's how the subsidy
uh works so those those were the the
version that came over from from the
Senate those are the four primary um uh
differences in the current benefit and
in this new
benefit that be glad to answer any other
questions this continues to say it
doesn't affect the sections dealing with
working after retirement so that someone
who were to
be um
retired due to due to this this
disability would still be limited to
part-time work if they were working for
a retirement system employer yes yes
that that that may be in fully worded
there were changes to in the previous
version about working after retirement
and um post-retirement death benefits
those were taken out in the version you
received so it's status quo um for the
working after retirement rules for the
50% Auto espousal uh benefit for group
two uh things like that that those those
are unchanged for this new
category thank you does anyone else have
questions representative
Brown uh thank you madam
chair thanks for taking my question
early early on you mentioned both group
one and group two but this is definitely
only group two correct yeah this is this
is group two only okay and this may not
be completely relevant but there are
people that work in group one that are
also exposed to this type of potential
injury inspectors of various nature um
going sometimes you have to take law
enforcement along so it would seem like
it might apply to group one as well
that's not really relevant I suppose
thank
you it depends on whether we're
expecting somebody to come over to the
DMV with with a pistol and and settle
their disputes violently I wouldn't
think it's that
likely may I would follow up having if I
may please
yeah I I'm a group one retiree worked at
Dees and there's a number of instances
where our inspectors especially when
you're tracking down people doing legal
disposal on their property and that type
of thing where you do take a law
enforcement officer with you or
sometimes not and and there have been
cases of of threatening with firearms
and that type of thing so thank you
madam shair appreciate that yes all
right well we I'm sure that if this
benefit is a success group one will be
coming after us in the
future any other questions from Mr Mr
car representative
broa I apologize for coming in late so
in the current statute it says
that people who are disabled who have um
additional compensation from a part-time
position or something that is taken into
account by the um in in their payment
but in their annual amount earned
whereas if House Bill 134
passes any type of gainful occupation
reporting would be would not be required
correct
yeah anyone else all right thank you
very much thank
you Kenneth Chamberlain
thank you would you have to turn your
mic on
please thank you sorry
no my name is Kenneth Chamberlain I'm
retired Manchester police officer
retired in
2019 I was an investigator in the
Traffic Unit served 2 7 and a half years
my first 11 years I worked in hookit I
was a patrol
Sergeant I was also held a position of
uh Union president with the Manchester
Police Department that held that
position until my retirement 2019 I'm
also past president of the New Hampshire
Police Association I was president in
2017 I still currently assist the New
Hampshire Police Association with um
lobbying um and also with uh charitable
fundraising
I'm here today in in support of Senate
Bill
134 so the the purpose of this bill is
to add a new section under accidental
disability and um and the accident of
disability retirement violent accident
disability retirement
allowance
so I have my prepared statement I'm
going to wander off this thing now just
listening to some of the stuff that's
been spoken to here so my the reason why
I got involved um obviously I'm close
friends with the andar through my work
with him through being his Union
president and also just from the stuff
that I've done with the Hampshire Police
Association and over the course of time
since 2012 just some of the things that
Dan's been dealing with things that have
come up um I just felt that um leg some
type of legislation was needed to try to
correct some of these things one of the
things if you look at um there's two
type of there's two type of uh
disability retirements in the state one
is accidental disability which is
something that happens when you when
you're working get injured and you and
you're permanently disabled the other
one's called Ordinary so one of the
conversations I had with Dan probably
half you know while into this um his his
journey now and his disability when I
found out that his his disability was
called accidental
disability my question to him was
accidental disability well this wasn't
an accident how is it called accidental
disability when it's not an accident so
the one thing is with this with this
whole
um what this whole bill is is dealing
with is everything that um would be
covered under here with these
disabilities they're not an accident
they're all intentional
acts and just listening to some of the
conversation I I feel for any employee
um someone that's going on a gas worker
utility person um that goes out to a
home someplace and and gets harassed or
maybe even gets attacked I feel for that
person in in this scenario in these
incidents that you're going to hear
they're going to speak to you and
they're going explain the scenarios that
they were in the the incidents that they
were
in they were purposely attacked um they
were targeted and attacked so it wasn't
like they just came upon something and
something just you know someone didn't
like the fact that their meter was being
read they were attacked with a specific
intent of causing harm or killing them
and the injuries that they sustained are
no different than if they were in combat
they're not clean injuries that the type
injuries that are ever developing
they're ever evolving they're Ever
Changing they're not an injury that you
have and it heals you might have a
disability from it but say you lost a
limb the limb is gone and you have to
figure out how to compensate for not
having that limb the injuries that they
have are um I can I'll use Dan as an
example who he'll probably come up and
tell you some of the stuff that he has
wrong with him but one of some of his
injuries uh he was shot six
times um he fell in he his left tibia
was shattered so it caused him to fall
on his
back um one of the bullets that was shot
at him went under his vest after he fell
down so it just bounced around inside
him because it wouldn't come out um it
caused just a ton of internal injuries
to his internal organs um intestines he
lost two feet of his intestines he has
um lead fragments in his body that they
can't take out and the reason they can't
take them out it's too risky so just
think about um you buy a house right now
and it's built before 1978 you have to
have a lead paint test done on it why is
that because you want to make sure
you're not going to get poison something
like that from the house he has lead in
his body and what is that going to do we
don't know what the cause what causes
that's going to have with him going in
the future but I'm I'm sure something's
going to happen with that um
um he's had um 19 major
surgeries um so I'm just giving you an
example like this and Paul Lewis um same
thing he he was shot in the arm um again
it's not a clean injury um he still
having issues with that and it's they're
ever developing injuries so that's part
of the that's part of the reason why
this bill is
important um so and know kind of over
the all over the place because I'm just
trying to answer some of the stuff that
you talked about
one of the things with these two offices
is the time that they had on when this
took place so Dan had three years and
nine months on when his incident took
place so when we started our journey
with this with this bill uh we actually
started back in 2019 is when we started
trying to put this together our
conversation started way before that to
get me motivated to actually start
putting the spill together that's you
know kind of looking at the time frame
um so when we were putting this together
and I'm looking at what his pension was
what they came out with his pension
um so the way the pension works it's the
average for a disability it's the
average of your five highest years so
we'll take Dan's example right now he
had three three years and nine months on
when his incident took place so to start
off with your you your first years are
generally your lowest years so Dan
actually um he tried coming back to work
he did he came back for seven years put
seven more years in during those seven
years like I said he had like 19 from
the beginning of his incident to when he
finished work and he had about 19 uh
major
surgeries during those
surgeries um he's out he's out of work
so when he's out of work um it's called
it's work is comp the way work as comp
works if you get hurt injured um and
you're going to be out of work it starts
off is sick time so we usually have
about three days of sick time it gives
Administration some time to get your
paperwork together to convert the sick
time to work as calm time and then that
sick time eventually converts to work as
calm time so one of Dan's goals was he
wanted to make 10 years so
psychologically however you want to look
at it he had a goal to make 10 years so
he thought he had over 10 years in I
think it was 10 years and 7 months 10
years in 9 months he went up to the
retirement and that's what he thought
his number was when they ran his number
they told him he had just over nine
years so he told him you need to go back
and recalculate that because that's not
what it is so they told him that the
time that you're out on work is calm is
not considered credible service
time so now think about that for a
minute the day the night he gets
shot that's a work day he's clearly
working so it's going to count as a work
day he's fighting for his life that
night next day he's still fighting for
his life the doctors don't know how he
lived the amount of blood that he lost
um it was incredible that his organs
didn't shut down um so the next day he's
clearly still fighting for his life
that's a sick day that sick day turned
into a work as comp day which then turns
into a non-credible service day so he's
being told that those days that he's
fighting for his life life are not
considered Federal service time so
psychologically how do you take that um
these are all things that fall into play
with this type of incident and injuries
and disability that these two officers
are dealing with and anyone else that
falls behind
them
so when they start calculating his time
even though he had um like I said over
10 years in the system when they started
calculating in his time they could only
come up with 4 and A2 years of actual
time because of the amount of time that
he missed on his surgeries so they had
to make up a half a year I don't know
how you factor that half a year to get
your your number to do your multiplier
but I know three and a half of those
years were his lowest would historically
would be his lowest time now you add in
the rest to make up your five years
what's the pension going to be and now
at that time he wasn't married he was
young um he's still obviously younger
than me he's still young um but he's
looking at a future where um you know
clearly he has a lot of medical stuff if
you look at him he might look like
there's nothing wrong with him
internally there's a lot wrong with
him just over a year ago he had um a
surgery where he had a blockage in his
intestines he'll you know he'll tell you
the stuff but he had blocket in his
intestines if you don't have an issue
with your intestines normally the
doctor's going to go in there and
they're going to do some surgery they're
going to they're going to unblock it
there was a very high risk of him going
septic obviously you don't want to have
that you you'll die from that in his
situation because of the scar tissue and
with the amount of um intestines that he
had lost any surgery that he has on his
intestines there's a risk that they
won't have enough to reattach it and now
he'll have a colomy bag um eventually at
some point that's probably going to
happen with him but they don't want to
they want to try to push that off as far
as they can can so again these are just
some of the things that they're dealing
with
um so when they factor out his you know
obviously his his his pension he he's
got this fiveyear pension and um again
it's historic the low historically it's
the lowest time I had said to Dan at
that when we were going through this
stuff can you imagine if someone had
less time on than you I mean your
Situation's bad enough but I can't
imagine someone have less time on than
you and then Paul Lewis comes along
eight months in the the job 8 months on
the job when his incident
happened how do you how do you factor
5ye average when you only worked eight
months not eight years eight months on
the job eight
months how do you come up with a pension
that is going to he's going to be able
to survive on um for the you know
basically for the rest of his life um so
that's why this tension was put together
um as far as like the gainful occupation
so at one point that gainful occupation
wasn't in play with this it happened in
2012 um I understand probably reason for
it um you could have someone slip and
fall these incidents are not a slip and
fall they didn't ask for it they had no
involvement at all in the injuries that
they had um potentially someone with a
slip and fall I mean are they hurt could
someone claim that they had injury and
now they're going out working another
job and they're double dipping so that
was put that was I'm assuming putting
play because they want to avoid that
potentially from
happening this here is not something
they asked for they want to they if they
had their way right now they'd be back
out in the street working as a police
officer and you look at you look at our
society right now it's very hard to find
police officers it's very hard to find
them they actually want to go out and
work Dan actually um
tried going
back over a year ago he actually passed
a PT test which was pretty heroic of him
doing that he paid for it though because
he couldn't walk for two weeks but um
it's just impossible for them to do that
they had careers taken away from them
their lives were put on hold financially
um like I said they have these ever
developing um injuries some of the stuff
that they'll have that they'll put
claims in for um like I said Dan had
that
um he had a titanium rod put in his left
leg uh one of one of the surgery he had
uh the bone was growing too much over
over the titanium rod they had to remove
it because it was causing stress between
his knee and his
ankle they had to use a violent tool to
pull that out he also Lo um his iliac
artery was uh ruptured they had to
remove that so he doesn't have iliac
artery in his left leg that's used for
blood circulation so he has a rod taken
out covered under workers comp I think
it was about a week later he had to go
back in for procedure to check to make
sure of the circulation because high
risk for blood clotting because he
doesn't have that
artery that surgery wasn't covered
initially because they said it wasn't
related to the initial incident how is
it not related to the initial incident
he doesn't have the artery now he has to
go fight that and this is a constant
thing that was happening with him um so
that's just an example but the reason
why this this bill is important um again
is because of these things that they're
dealing with the injuries are not the
same the gainful occupation it's not so
much that they want to be able to go out
and work a 40-hour week job they want to
feel like a whole person um their life
was taken away from them they want to
feel like they have psychologically that
they that they have a purpose um you
know they they have families you know
and they want to be able to say that um
you know they they can be productive or
or they're not being held back they're
getting their life back now whether they
can actually work a 40-hour week job or
not that's irrelevant the fact that
someone's not telling them that they
don't that they can't do that so that
it's a psychological part it's not
because they want to go out and say I
want I want to get rid of the gainful
occupation because I want to be able to
go work another job so I can make a lot
of money that's not really the reason
for it in this case it's a psychological
reason why they want to have it and
again it's not the injuries AR anything
that they had any part in someone else
did did this to them it should not apply
to them
so I like I said I I handed out my my um
prepared statement I can go back to the
thing I skipped over some stuff you're
more than welcome to read it um I'll
take questions if you want it but uh I
just ask you support in this
Bill thank you representative
Shu thank you madam chair um I've had
the honor to meet offic Doty and um was
well aware of his literally miraculous
survival and attempts to return to work
so thank you for the update on how he's
fairing now I'm curious um with the look
back in this bill to
2018 would both of these officers be
included in that that was the reason for
that and as far as
um I don't know the number of people
that would be qualified under this
they're the only two that we're aware
of thank
you thank you very
much thank you
okay I suppose we should hear from Don
derty please
we'll we'll
share good afternoon uh thank you for
the opportunity to speak in in front of
you folks
um I had a script that I'm certainly
gonna deviate from
um so back in 2012 uh as a Manchester
police officer uh I was shot six times
assisting uh other
officers who observed the violent career
criminal um involved in an alocation uh
remove himself from a vehicle with what
appeared to be a gun under his shirt in
his
waistband um I was on a swap that day I
wasn't supposed to be working um I was
actually going on vacation trying to
work some days off and I wasn't
certainly wasn't supposed to be on the
west side of manchest
um I was close by to the Grand Street
bridge I jumped over and I helped locate
the
individual upon doing that he um fled on
foot uh through one
firearm and uh a foot pursuit ensued um
eventually I was able to catch up to him
and uh once I closed the Gap he removed
the second firearm from his waistband
and shot 15 rounds at me six of which
struck me in my lead my uh leg groin
face hand and uh
abdomen and uh luckily I was behind the
greatest Hospital in the world at least
in my opinion because they saved my life
the the Catholic Medical Center and I am
here today because of the folks there um
I went through 18 units of blood the
body holds approximately nine um and
somehow um some way I
survived and the detail details can go
on forever about the story um but I'm
not necessarily here to bore you with
those details um I'm here
to um explain to you the cause in which
I firmly believe in um in 2019 I'm sorry
at the end of
2018 after 19 surgeries I had to retire
um I didn't want to but I kept having
surgery after surgery after surgery
after surgery to help continue being a
police officer to make sure that I'm
physically able to and it came to a
point where I was no longer able to do
that and it was very hard but I had to
and I retired and it was at that point
where I took um Ken chamelin off to the
side and I said we need to fix the
retirement system uh for people in my
position um we need to create a benefit
that's focused more towards um um a
violent attack rather than an accident
and I can assure you that there was
nothing accidental about the person who
tried to kill me um and when I was
laying in my hospital bed um I was very
fortunate at the time that I wasn't
married um I didn't have children but I
can only imagine how much more of a
burden that recovery would be had I been
married had a CH had children because
laying in that bed wondering how I'm
going to if I wasn't able to return to
work how was I going to be able to
provide um how was I going to have
health insurance um what what was I
gonna do and this bill here uh
specifically touches upon I think what
is uh three of the most important
um fault is a bad word but but um um
things that that that should be changed
for people in my position and that's
your your really benefit um the
healthare and the gainful occupation so
the $75,000 a year that would increase
for me specifically um my my benefit
each year is
$46,000 so if this piece of legislation
were to go through it would go from
$46,000 to
$75,000 and uh with that being said is
someone I know recently he heard his
back on the job and he went out on
accidental disability the same
accidental disability that I receive his
pension is uh nearly triple mine and um
that is another reason why I feel that
that basing it off of a high fiveyear
average where most young cops don't have
that because most young cops are the
ones out in the street responding to the
most dangerous of situations because as
you go on in your career you're usually
off the
street um and then the the the
healthcare subsidy um I felt that that
was important and in fact originally
that wasn't even a thought of mine to
even include this but um some some
Senators s suggested that we do that um
and here it is it's in there um and I
thank them for that and then the gainful
occupation that doesn't cost the state a
dime um you know I'm capped as to how
much money I I can make a year I would
like to wake up every morning get in a
routine go to a job um go go to a
Christmas party socialize um earn
benefits um and I feel that the gainful
occupation really limits that um and
every year that cap changes based on
this the consumer sound index um if I'm
saying that
correctly and you know I sell boats I
broker boats and I I say that because
last year I didn't make a dime doing it
because the econom is so bad and
interest rates that
had it been a great year and I met my
cap this year or I went over my cap this
year I'd be penalized where we're
probably going to have another bad year
so the gainful occupation I understand
its purpose but in this situation um we
feel necessary to to remove it um just
to be a productive me member of society
because I would like to work a full-time
job
um and um
um you know at at the end of the day
with the restrictions with the
legislation regarding the New Hampshire
retirement system I almost feel like I
being punished for surviving there's a
whole slew of
benefits uh that are in place through
legislation for um the family of the
fallen officers um or or or or or
firemen uh for group two um and that
that restriction I unfortunately feel
like it's a punishment
um and just because I had uh just under
four years on the
job um had I been on longer I would have
received um a higher monetary benefit
and at 45 years old this restriction
goes away I'm not sure what the
difference between 25 years old that I
was when the shooting happened in 45
years old that cap to me just doesn't
make sense if if this a cap there's a
cap if there's not there's not I don't
necessarily understand the 45 years old
um and um you
know this the the six years that I
returned as a police officer it was
interrupted by a surgery I'd be out for
two months three months four months five
months at times eight months so I was
never able to get a full complete year
after the shooting therefore my pension
benefit is limited um and to be told at
a meeting with the New Hampshire di
system when I went there knowing I had
10 and a half years of service they told
me I had eight eight years like 8.2
years and I politely asked what about
the other two and a half years and they
said well you didn't get credit for all
the time well they said more than likely
you weren't getting credit for all the
times that you were out injured the
initial year and then all the follow-up
surgeries and I found that to be pretty
upsetting considering that the hardest
I've ever worked was following the
shooting and recovering I was fighting
for my life but not getting credit
um and
um and all all the battles W with with
workers comp um that in itself was a
post-traumatic stress um uh diagnosis
dealing with that um I had that were in
collection agencies I I was in um in
monetary distress because of some of
these bills that weren't being covered
um specifically soft tissue that has to
do with your organs my legs my my uh my
bones no question but when it came to
organs sorry that's not covered
um so that in itself was just a battle
and that's a whole different slew of
legislation that that that needs to be
fixed um but I don't know if I can take
take take that on as well um but I want
to thank you for your time and and
listening to me um any questions that
you might have feel
free thank you Mr dty I'm very glad you
survived that our deal as well as you
did thank you and we will have to look
into why time out on workers comp
doesn't apply to your pension because
that seems like a systemic problem not
just with with people who are
permanently disabled but people who are
out for a shorter period of time but
anyway are there any
questions I don't see any thank you very
much thank
you uh Paul Lewis
good afternoon everybody U my name is
Paul Lewis I'm one of the two officers
that we know will be directly benefiting
from the bill and I would like to say
it's it's never easy sharing the story
so um I do my best but it's it can be
difficult we'll take your word for it
okay okay we're we're already an hour
late so we'll uh any brevity is
appreciated all right I'll stick I'll
stick to the point uh a subtle backstory
so I had a dream of doing as much good
as I could in this this world I I got a
master's degree in social work with um
the motivation to then become a police
officer I wanted to understand why
people commit the crimes and um get
ahead of of the issues and and uh be the
best police officer I could I had a lot
of Dreams in the career eight months out
of the police academy I was called to a
domestic where a husband was holding his
wife hostage with multiple Firearms she
was able to sneak away for a couple
seconds text her parents who called us
and uh we went there uh when we got to
the house um he was in fact holding her
hostage with multiple Firearms we put
oursel my sergeant and I uh in we're in
New Hampshire it's a only 12 officer
Department it was just us on we put
ourselves in between the husband and the
wife uh when we did that he shot six
times at us and two hit me in my
dominant arm we were able to save her
but my life was then on the line was an
artery was severed and um I was bleeding
out quickly luckily we had a tourniquet
that was put on me and I got rushed to
the hospital and my life was saved uh
when I woke up I was told by the surgeon
that I had permanent nerve damage and I
would likely never be able to use my
dominant hand again I spent the next
three years um undergoing five surgeries
trying to learn how to live life
left-handed I I only had one hand and I
lost my full Independence I I needed
help eating shaving showering everything
I I still can't really write to this
this day so I I I was I moved to New
Hampshire to become a police officer I
was such an independent person and now I
Rely um on so many people for everything
I had a dream to return but it was
determined it was too unsafe for me to
do so the hardest part of it all was um
after I retired October
2021 I was told what my benefits would
be at the time I was making
$21.50 an hour I found out my benefit is
66% of that so my total pension is
$29,000 per year on top of that I have
to pay my own health insurance in in
fact I went in front of the town awar uh
right after I retired and I asked for
Aid in health insurance they said
they'll pay half of it for a year and
then I'm on my own I returned a year
later and I said I can't afford this can
you please help me at least until we
figure out the end result of this bill
they said no you're too
expensive so a large portion of my my uh
benefit is taken from the health
insurance and I'm single I'm unmarried I
can't rely on anybody else to help me
with with this health insurance and then
uh F the difficulty I'm capped on my
earnings we're only allowed to fill in
that last 33% of the 66 we make so I'm
only allowed
$20,000 per year I don't know what I'm
capable of yet I can't write I I can I
could barely butt in these shirts today
but I would like to eventually find out
what I am capable of with the
limitations on this
cap what can I do making $20,000 per
year it's almost like count myself out
because there's any job would make more
than that and when I start to then
they'll start taking my pension any
motivation is just completely lost by
that number um I'm having difficulties
surviving based on that 29,000 I I get
support from my family I I found a
roommate to to help me pay bills but I I
wasn't working in a big city I was
pretty much on my own since the incident
happened and it seems like every time I
asked for help I'm just told I'm too
expensive and I'm thrown away I don't
even hear from the town anymore and
fortunately I found the people behind me
to help me fight through my battles uh
Dan and I the only two officers in New
Hampshire that have survived a shooting
and medically retired we've been there
for each other and uh he's been my
number one support and if there were any
others I'm sure that uh we would have
found them we're a small community here
but it's just been us two
and I really just beyond anything else
I'm hopeful that you all will consider
helping us it's a very small number
people that will be helped in we
desperately need it we've had a lot of
setbacks both of us every time we get up
for in the door we have a setback and we
need an additional surgery and it's just
been non-stop so I'm hopeful that um you
give us the opportunity to to
strive well thank you for your testimony
and again congratulations on Surviving
your ideal your ordeal as well as you
have thank you so much are there any
questions don't see any thank thank you
very much thank you
all Carl
farington I'm sorry I forgot to give my
written testimony can I we'll we'll pass
it along thank
you is
on I'm call with the uh currently still
with the Lawrence Police Department down
in Massachusetts uh Derry New Hampshire
resident uh New Hampshire resident for
about 25 years now I was born and raised
in Lawrence followed a career in law
enforcement uh from my family
grandfather great uncle uncle uh my
great-grandfather was a uh a fireman and
I also served as the police chief excuse
me the fire
chief uh I started my career up in
Raymond New Hampshire back in the late
'90s just after the uh Claremont
shooting of Troopers uh and officers up
there uh still wanted to get in the job
uh also uh the Epsom officer just after
that I still wanted to get into the job
um I started up in New Hampshire I
worked there a few years and decided to
go back to my hometown uh down in
Lawrence um and worked hard I uh I can't
tell you how many times I was injured
how many times I was violently
attacked um stick stuck with needles hit
with bats hit with pipes hit with fist
hit with Brocks um hit with cars over
and over again over the years did I take
much time out no I was a hard worker you
know officers of that personality where
you just want to go help people and
that's who I was I started up here
wanting to help what I could oui or DWI
I think you call them up and uh just
trying to people off the road you know
help save lives and I couldn't tell you
how many lives I
saved not to cut you short but could you
give us some information on why you're
in favor of the bill in 2020 I uh we're
tracking um a crew of um an robbers just
going around the city random attack
people um I had uh was we have cameras
throughout the city I was trying to
track it down on the the cameras trying
to see Vehicles whatever we could find
out so even if you weren't involved they
didn't hit your sector of town all the
officers were involved uh then I
responded to a uh they call it be
breaking an entry uh which later was
found out was attempted home invasion
three men ran into the apartment with
guns blazing fortunately there was
nobody home uh another officer arrived
and his partner Brookie just out of the
academy uh first day um they arrived
moments before me they're confronting
three suspects getting into a car I pull
on the parking lot I see something going
on uh I stop at the gate as I'm getting
out of the cruiser uh that vehicle flees
from those offices and as it flees it
does a little button hook around my
cruiser to head for the uh the gate
which the cruiser was in front of and
obviously me at that point I had just
exited the cruiser I got slammed up
against the uh Cruiser by his vehicle as
he attempted to flee the um the crimes
that were committing um my ankle my left
ankle was probably 75 80% ripped off um
I got pushed through the vehicle and
thrown they estimated like 15 fet it's
all caught on video um and then the
suspect ran me over um my knees totally
out of line uh I uh like I said the
ankle I've had numerous surgeries over
and over again um attempt to save
attempt to Hope hopefully I'll have
movement you know I can't feel a
majority of my foot I can't move it uh
but on the inside I feel it constantly
constant headache constant pain I'm
still in need of two total knee
Replacements uh I haven't done that yet
because of financial difficulties um
right away you know I'm out injured I'm
just trying to walk again didn't walk
for a year and a half uh a lot of the
guys didn't touch on the Family Impact
and I'll just say that my family was
devastated I'm the longone worker within
that household you know my wife wanted
to be a good mother and be home with the
kids and I had their opportunity to work
over time and help raise a family and
that's what we're doing so then we're
all of a sudden thrown into me making
you know minimum amount of money and
trying to raise a family sure our
friends help trying to raise this for us
it helped tremendously but the college
fund starts dis appearing all the
fundraisers quickly disappear you know
and then fighting with the insurance
companies you know I was getting bills
for major surgeries it's like didn't you
guys know this was part of my injury uh
and it's just this constant battle which
and then just trying to buy things to
survive with learning how to sit on the
toilet you you're building up your
bathroom with all the you know the
handicap abilities I can't tell you how
many times I was on the floor crying my
butt off uh in front of My Wife and Kids
so my kids have been affected because of
the injury just watching me a guy that
was always a high charger want to play
with the kids when I was out of work I
was with my family uh and then they saw
me sitting on a recliner for a year and
a half trying to recover uh then when I
started walking again sure the pain sets
in even more so I'm sure I wasn't too
Pleasant at that point and then the
aggravation of knowing that I'm not that
hot charger I was I wasn't saving lives
I wasn't trying to uh you know be a good
man be a good father be a good husband
you know and the devastation that that
put on me and my family was crazy
and um so right now we're still fighting
down in Massachusetts for Bill similar
to this to pass uh you know and these
guys talked about the ability to work I
I wanted to take courses I you know I
know I can't go back to the job um but I
want to take courses my whole life was
dedicated to police work so I want to
take a course to learn how to do
something and if I become good at it
then you're going to limit me on what I
can make which it doesn't seem right it
seems like you want to provide as much
as you can for your family I was unable
to help my girls with vehicles when
they're growing up all of a sudden they
had to start working my wife had to
start working um you know everything
just disappeared money and uh you know
now it's prom season my daughter's
asking not a lot she's just looking for
flowers I can't even get a flowers at
this point it's it's it's quite the
burden I just I'm here to support it I
intend to talk I'm sorry from Ramblin uh
I hope you guys just think about the
impact that it has on both family and
friends I have uh guys at work that uh
PTSD just watched me on the ground I got
knocked out I had brain damage so they
thought I was dead you know they see my
legs flailed apart my ankle ripped off
um poor kid first night on the job that
could have been him where would he be
right now and you know his ability to
earn money and how much would he be
making on retirement but you get a guy
like me who' been on for 25 years and
I'm still fighting every day and just
the block that I walked to get here
today you know the pain is intense the
mind starts going num this vision gets
blurry because of the pain do I take
medications the rest of my life and just
be a you know a burden to that I don't
want to be I want to be a productive
member of society and I hope you guys uh
pass this bill any questions
repres representative gold thank you
madam chair and thank you for um taking
my my question although at the risk of
Madam chair's ey I just want to make a
comment thank you very much for your
testimony I'm very aware this committee
is very aware of the effects of PTSD on
those in your situation so regardless of
what this committee does with this bill
you're all very valued and we appreciate
your service and we wish the this system
wasn't so broken for you thank you thank
you thank
you Mar
Ola good afternoon thank you madam chair
members of the committee my name is
Mario ala I'm a retired police detective
from the city of sumerville
Massachusetts I was shot in the line of
Dy on November 2nd 2010 I was shot six
times died three times in the hospital
that evening and by the grace of God was
brought
back I was married at the time with a
three-year-old boy and later learned
when I got home from the hospital that
my wife was pregnant I ended up having
another child N9 months later so I was
left with sitting at home making 72% of
my pay a little bit more than half to
try to
sustain a life for a young
family um I'd like to educate you a
little bit on what an officer would get
if they died in the line of duty in this
case we're in New Hampshire officer Dar
and officer Lewis had they died the
evening that they were shot their
spouses would have received a one-time
Federal payment of
$437,500
taxfree from the federal government the
state of New Hampshire gives a
$100,000 tax-free payout it's different
a mass it's 300,000 a mass the espouses
or beneficiary would receive 100% of
their base salary at the rank that they
held at the time of their death okay
their children if they had children
would receive instate College tuition
for free four
years however because they were brave
enough to
survive they both received 66 and 23%
half for their pay so what's the message
that this state is sending to your
officers you're worth more dead than you
are
alive I know it's not any of your fault
like ma' what you said it's a broken
system but you have an opportunity to
fix
it okay it's horrific it's sad that an
officer has to be punished financially
speaking for surviving an
ordeal it shouldn't be like this this is
America the greatest country on on Earth
we are better than this we need to fix
it thank you thank you and again
congratulations on surviv I hope that
this committee votes favorably on this
bill and passes it thank you for your
time representative Schmidt has a
question yes
sir thank you madam chair uh Mr
ol um
I I I I'm I'm asking you the questions
because it seems like just possible that
you're not in as much pain right at the
moment as some of the previous Witnesses
have
been uh I I I was part of this committee
when we passed the bill that gave the
$100,000 death benefit to police
officers and
firefighters
okay um but I'm astonished that to hear
that that the insurance cover
is as minimal as it is in terms
of even covering the bills that you all
have had um I'm and I'm wondering
whether I ask you just as a technical
question have have any of you been
counseled and maybe you know because you
seem to be quite
knowledgeable um have any of you been
counseled to sue the state or your the
department involved
D for the damage that was inflicted on
you obviously against your will with no
intent on your part by somebody who was
in the act of committing a crime for
which they probably um uh have been
sentenced to a long time in prison so
can you tell me whether you've ever been
cons advised to sue the state or the
department because
great harm has been done to you and your
colleagues that have spoken before you
sir uh I'll try to answer your question
sir thank you so the laws are obviously
different in mass than they are in New
Hampshire in in
Massachusetts we have individual
Retirement Systems and in the city of
Somerville we had our own um separate
retirement system the retirement system
pays my base salary 100% of my base
salary I pay my insurance through it's
deducted through my the 100% income that
I make on a monthly basis as far as
filing lawsuit against the subject who
shot me he's dead I'm not I can't sue
anybody so every situation is different
um could we potentially possibly but it
it's just it draws out the process these
folks are traumatized enough as it is
going through what they've gone through
as have I what we want is to remedy have
a an equitable Fair process that we can
retire with dignity and move on with our
lives and to Echo what my brothers and
blue have said earlier we just want to
be productive members of society and be
treated fairly and be be able to earn
and take care of our families what do we
do to deserve this other than put on our
our uniforms and our badge and have the
courage to go out on the street and take
care of criminals and make lives easier
for you fine folks and your families
that you love
dearly that's what what we're guilty of
doing our
jobs and I'll tell you I'll close with
this police officers are the guardians
of our communities without them we have
chaos and Anarchy we owe it to them to
take care of them when they need us just
like you you deserve to be taken care of
by us when you need
us so again I ask for your support and
hopefully pass this Bill thank you so
much for your time
any
questions thank you
no anyone else wish to testify on Senate
Bill
134 Mr
der to to answer your um question
specifically I did approach the the the
city of Manchester regarding your
question
and I was told that we can't set
precedent um and that was the end of
that and as far as any type of
lawsuit it just what wasn't considered
we were more insulted by the response
than anything and we just let it go but
um with respect to this most recent
Amendment prior
to I'm very well invested in in law
enforcement in in the fire world in the
state of New
Hampshire and any major incident where
someone got seriously injured that would
qualify for accidental disability I
assure you I would know about it and I
do know of incidents however Paul Lewis
and I are the only two current
accidental disability benefit recipients
currently that would qualify for what's
in in front of you now since the
amendment I'm not exactly sure what that
has changed but prior to this amendment
Paul Lewis and I are the only two that
currently receive this this so as far as
thei Financial
impact in my opinion it's grossly
overestimated considering that in our
estimates that it would be about two
$200,000 a year approximately thank you
thank you thank
you anyone else okay I'm going to close
the hearing on Senate Bill 134 and open
the hearing on Senate Bill 600 and and
sponsor on all the rest good
luck just
sure I understand
that change
gears thank you very much the floor is
yours thank you and good afternoon Mr
chair and members of the committee um I
appreciate uh you having me here today
my name is Shannon chandley and I serve
the people of Senate District 11 um I
come before you today to introduce
Senate Bill
600 um Senate Bill 600 is a result of
information I learned from a constituent
and that is that um pharmacy technicians
are not members of the board that
certifies them and that they are in fact
prohibited from being on the Board of
Pharmacy that is because
um the board can consist only of
Pharmacists in its current form only
Pharmacists and uh members of the public
but the member of the public cannot in
fact be a pharmacy technician or the
spouse of one so what happens then is
that pharmacy technicians cannot serve
on the board which is in fact
responsible for their certification
um when I learned this it seemed like it
would be reasonable to add them and I
reached out to a number of stakeholders
and um there was uh great um uh
concurrence that this probably should
happen that I don't believe that we have
other boards where a person is subject
to the um rule of the board but is not
allowed to be a me that no one in that
profession is allowed to be a member so
the bill does that it uh adds
the um pharmacy technician to the board
and there are some rules around how that
is done
um the bill
also uh what the bill also does is um
change the number of um folks on the
pharmacy board actually it it clears up
some discrepancy because currently
there's actually a little bit of
discrepancy people were testifying at
the Senate hearing that there were X
number of uh people on the board and
others said why so what it does is
clarifies this and this is in
conjunction with a number of folks who
um agreed that this was the right number
that it would include it would be seven
members including five practicing
pharmacists at least one of whom is a
full-time Hospital pharmacist one
pharmacy technician and one public
member so um now you will also notice
that the title of the bill says relative
relative to Board of Pharmacy and
certified public accountant
examinations and um that was uh that was
a second uh uh my colleague Senator
Fenton brought that Amendment to the um
there was actually a second hearing for
a non- gerain Amendment so what uh he
had um introduced the amendment at the
request of the New Hampshire Board of
accountancy and it is in relation to the
um administration of exams uh by the
national state boards of accountancy um
the New Hampshire Board of accountancy
is adopting a 30mon limit in its rules
but there was an
18month limit in statute so what it does
is it requires that uh folks taking this
exam have to pass all parts of the exam
within the uh time that would be uh the
specific time frame requirement would be
taken from statute and adopted through
rules of the board um that is the second
part of this bill I hope that you will
look favorably upon um both parts of the
bill and I want to express that um my uh
one of my constituents did come to the
Senate hearing uh she was not able to
come to this hearing she is in fact
working but uh she spoke really
passionately about how important the
role of pharmacy technician is is and um
she talked about how patient care is at
the core of their profession and
Pharmacy uh technicians interview
patients for medication reconciliation
they administer intravenous solutions
they run fusion centers and they serve
on Hospital committees she's passionate
about her work she is a professional and
she really um wants to uh make sure that
the entire profession is recognized as
such and accorded a place on the board
so thank you for your test for your uh
time and your consideration and I hope
that you will um find in favor of this
Bill thank you thank you for Testimony
Senator any questions yes representative
leus thank you it's um technical
question and if you wanted to defer to
director Courtney you just arrived
that's fine and that's uh page one lines
19 to 21 it says the pharmacy technician
member of the board shall have been
certified and it goes on um it is my
understanding that relatively recently
there was the addition in addition to
pharmacy technicians being able to be
certified uh there's also a license and
my question is does this Lang would this
language include Pharmacy and
technicians that are licensed as well as
ones that are certified as possible
members on the
board yes um it would include and and I
can and certainly um if I am I'm missp
speaking uh director Courtney can
correct me but I believe that it does
include them one of the issues is we do
not have a number of those folks
practicing here because as you know that
is a new standard so we I thought you
were going to ask me about the 10-year
requirement because we did um bat that
idea around we wondered if in fact maybe
pharmacy technicians we would say uh
five year at practicing for at least
five years but um the standard is in
line with the pharmacist practice for 10
years we do have a number of Highly
qualified pharmacy technicians who've
been practicing in the state for 10
years so we will we chose that we do not
have a number of folks who are the um
advanced practice
folks uh followup followup so if you
have somebody let's say they presumably
they're certified and then they become
licensed
um then even though they're licensed if
they're certified as well and they've
been doing it for 10 years 5 Years in
New Hampshire then presumably they'd be
eligible is that correct yes okay thank
you you're welcome any other
questions seeing none thank you for very
much representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
wanted to recognize the senator for
bringing this bill forward to the Senate
hopefully onto that the house I fully
support the bill uh not per se as
written but the inent of the bill if I
could also before I get into my um
discussion of testimony before this
committee I introduce who I am um Gary
Merchant for the record um
representative from salivan County
district 6 which is Claymont in Cen also
I am a past board member of the Board of
Pharmacy for 10 years serving also as
the president of the board
in regards to the question if a licensed
Advanced pharmacy technician could
become quote a member of the board as it
stands today it may be a problem because
in order to become a licensed technician
you only need to have 2,000 hours as a
certified tech which is not 10 years so
that could be problematic where all of a
sudden we have somebody who actually has
a higher standard of practice but is not
eligible for the board based upon the
way the laws written currently before
you cuz they would not have a full 10
years I would also think about when
you're looking at a pool of candidates
many technicians who are highly
qualified and hav't practiced in the
field for many years they're essential
to the practice of Pharmacy they are
critical to allowing us to do the work
we have to do however the turnover rate
is extremely high so therefore 10 years
could be honorous to have somebody in
the field for 10 10 years when it's more
of a job versus a career I would say if
you're looking at changing something
maybe 5 years is more amable um I would
also say two years in the state of New
Hampshire um at that point in time if
you want to look at the licensed
technicians hopefully by the time this
gets through we'll have a pull of
candidates we can draw upon who our
licensed as
well I would ask the board to consider
the effective date of this bill to move
it out and the rationale to that is
currently on the board there is a
natural Evolution you cannot serve for
more than two consecutive 5-year
terms there is a individual on the board
today who's going to come to the end of
their second five-year term next
September there's an individual on the
board today who's in the first five-year
term if this is effective in August to
September they would not qualify for
being on the board for the second
opportunity
if we extend the effective date until
January 1st
2025 then would be effective in
September when the natural cycle
somebody coming off the board so we
would not as a legislative body
inadvertently take someone off the board
that may not want to come off the board
so I would say could we somehow make the
effective data at least the beginning of
the year January
1st 2025
in regards
to the pharmacy technicians again there
is the licensed Pharmacy technition it
is just started we have our first
individual who actually is first in the
nation I'm kind of proud about that
being from New Hampshire myself uh New
Hampshire leading the way um but we have
a lot of interest in the field in the
profession to have more licensed
technicians and the rationale to why we
have a licensed technician versus a
certified technician
as a licensed pharmacist if I have a
certified
technician doing
task and something happens
inadvertently it never falls to the
technician it's always on my license so
therefore to break it apart to reduce
the liability exposure of the pharmacist
we created a licensed technition like
you do an LPN under the RN so that they
have their own distinct license and
their own liability and also with that
the training it goes to acquire it so it
encouraged the bo this board or this
committee to think about making a
modification so that we can have
licensed technicians on the board like
we do licensed pharmacist I'll be
willing to sit down with someone on the
committee and write an
amendment um to try to weave that
through here and try to at that point in
time bring something back to the
committee or back to somebody on this
committee and introduce an amendment
through one of the members on the
committee
thank you very much any questions yes
representative Le related to the last
question I asked and that is um for
someone to be a licensed uh pharmacy
technician do they also have to be
certified yes they have to be certified
and practicing for a minimum of 2,000
hours which is basically a year follow
up follow up then um wouldn't the
language here that says uh to be a
member of the board they shall be cert
they have to be certified wouldn't that
language be okay and apply both to
certified and licensed pharmacy
technicians if to be licensed they have
to be certified the way it's written now
it requires 10 years the licensed te
only requires one year follow up follow
no I'm not talking about the length of
time but if if I understand correctly
and if for a pharmacy TCH technician to
be licensed they also have to be
certified you know they're they're both
then um I would think both the number of
years and the presence on the board
would be permitted for licensed or
certified ones um given this language
and it would not need to be changed
other than the number of years is that
am I incorrect or not the way I read it
now in order to be candidate you have to
have 10 years as a certified tech to be
a licensed technician you only need one
year so therefore if you become licensed
as a technician after one year you don't
have a full 10 years as a certified Tech
just for clarification maybe I think I
may be wrong on this but here's you
don't have to go for lure is that cor do
you have to go for license you can stay
certified so the the point that you're
making is that you could be 10 years
certified and be on the board and have a
lower credential than a licensed
individual um because they can get it
after one year but you could just be
certified after 10 and be on the board
and so you'd have a lower license lower
credential person on to the chair if I
could if we could uh ask if I could ask
a question of Courtney when she comes up
I might be able to clarify this thank
you yeah absolutely representative
SMI thank you Mr chairman so
representative um with all due
respect it it seems to me that nobody
knows uh better than uh pharmacists
himself or herself um what the value uh
and the importance of the pharmac
Texas um you have to do is remember the
um It's a Wonderful Life a great story
of the worker
who discovers the mistake the pharmacist
has
made um but anyway bottom line is why do
you need an extra person on the
board uh pharmacists don't take care of
the pharmacy text we do but if I may
chman we do I would say the real value
of the board or any board is a very
diverse body because everyone brings a
different set of lens to the discussion
so when we're talking about things now
with a licensed
technician when certified they don't
come before the board for disciplinary
actions a licensed technician will come
before the board so having a licensed
technician on that board Who Walks In
Those Shoes helping that discussion with
the board I think is going to be
incredibly important and that's why I'm
really advocating more for the licensed
technician versus a certified technician
because the roles they play are
fundamentally
different so back to your question is I
think it's really important for any
board to be as diverse as possible so
that when something becomes before the
board there somebody on the board who
can bring that background that
experience that robustness to that
discussion
okay good representative gold thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um so and I don't know if this
needs to go to subcommittee I don't want
to waste a lot of time on this but my
question has to do with difference
between certified and
licensed uh kind of following up on that
greater credential comment that was made
earlier can you say that briefly or do
we need more time no it's
basically there are three levels of
technicians in the pharmacy World there
somebody who's registered as a
technician and that's there so he can
track what's going on to with diversion
of control drugs there's a certified
tech who goes through a certification
process and there also a licensed
technician the licensed technician is
the highest level and they have a
discrete license of their own unlike
everyone else and as a license holder
they are therefore accountable to the
Hampshire Board of Pharmacy certified
technicians per se have some
accountability but the certification is
not held by the state of New Hampshire
it's held by a National Organization so
we cannot pull their
certification okay a license on the
other hand issued by the state the state
can pull that license but we cannot pull
the
certification follow up and so is there
a longer training period or more
education like what gives the
licensed uh technician the higher
credential then besides the fact the
state has some control over it good
question they have to work as a
certified tech for at least 2,000 hours
they have to pass the law basically the
same law exam the pharmacist has to pass
they have to go through educational
training above and beyond that so
there's a lot of requirements that were
put into place in order to ensure that
once they get the license they can do it
safely and effectively
y yes representative leus um given how
much we're behind mind if this is going
to go to subcommittee if uh Madam not
chair at the moment uh can let us know I
will defer any of my further questions
to try and straighten out my
understanding until then okay sounds
like there's
questions thank
you thank you representative I
appreciate it yeah that that should be
it thank you unless you want to join the
subcommitte thank you thank you will I
will try to make myself a ailable to the
subcommittee to try to answer some of
his questions uh the other one also
could probably help out is
representative roord um who also a
serves on this Pharmacy board we're
trying to be sure whatever we do we do
correctly long term great thank you very
much does anybody else wish to testify
on S
sp600 uh director
Courtney question of the chair is there
somebody here that with a pink card with
regard to the pharmacy as far the
accountancy board no there's issue thank
you thank you Mr chair I'm members of
the committee Lindsay Courtney executive
director oplc I'll be very brief I know
this is uh likely to go to subcommittee
um the office is not taking a position
on the bill but I do think it's
important that um the Board of Pharmacy
be essentially be reconstituted in
statute um because there were
essentially three changes to the
pharmacy board composition last session
and there was a dispute currently um
internally uh with both the Department
of Justice and the Secretary of State as
to how many people are on the Board of
Pharmacy so um I think in order to
clarify that uh there needs to be a
statutory change uh confirming that it's
either five or confirming that it's
seven which is currently opl C's
position and the department of Justice's
position um so that we we know precisely
who has to be on the board um I think
representative leas uh there are some
there might be some confusion um there's
so to be an advanced a licens advanced
pharmacy technician you do have to have
your certification for one year but you
don't need to maintain it so you don't
need to maintain it concurrently um so I
think that hopefully maybe that clears
up a little bit there are three types of
certification or three types of licenses
under the Board of Pharmacy as it
relates to pharmacy technicians one is
called a a registered pharmacist or
pharmacy technician it's a registry
because there are no requirements other
than you be a certain age and we put you
on the registry under the administrative
procedures act it's still considered a
license so you still need to do process
if we're going to discipline you the
same is true with respect to
certification certification requires a
national certification we call it a
certification in New Hampshire but it's
still considered a license um that can
be subject to revocation after notice
and opportunity to be heard and then
there's the license Advanced pharmacy
technician so as as the bill is
currently drafted in order to be
eligible you would have to be in the
middle tier Certified Pharmacy
Technician um you could theoretically be
an advanced pharmacy technician if you
otherwise satisfy that requirement that
you have served um as a Certified
Pharmacy Technician for 10
years I'm happy to make myself available
at subcommitte and work with anybody to
get this done I think we just need a
bill uh on the other piece to clarify
who on the board thank you thank you
very
much is there anybody else who would
wish to testify on S
sp600 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing on SB
600 been using my pen all day instead of
the
G you
man and I will move right into opening
the public hearing on SP 480
is there anybody here to introduce that
bill
ah representative Maguire is here to rep
to introduce the bill yes thank you
I'm I'm Carol Maguire representing March
District 27 that is Allenstown Dunbarton
Epsom and hooks it I am not a sponsor of
House Bill 4 AV I'm introducing it as a
um as a favor to Senator Carson who has
had a different U Bill to introduce
elsewhere
today and I don't know anything about it
that you don't know from reading the
bill so I will not take any
questions thank you very
much uh I'd like to call Rob uh Bob
Quinn and Janie McIntyre
we can hopefully give us a little bit
more
information good afternoon my name is
Bob Quinn I'm the CEO of the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors and
I'm Joanie McIntyre I'm the president of
the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors so I'm going to give a quick
synopsis of the first section of the
bill and then Joanie will talk about the
remainder um so section one uh has to do
with it doesn't specifically pertain to
the Real Estate Commission but rather
any uh border commission who has active
lienes that exceed 7,000 would have
their own dedicated customer service
administrator so the real estate I think
they're about 10,000 um real estate
licenses in the state the Real Estate
Commission up until a couple years ago
had its own executive director um so it
was somebody who all lenses sort of knew
who they were could call email have have
a Communications back and forth if they
had any questions few years ago I think
that that executive director position
morphed a little bit and they started to
oversee some other smaller boards as
well um so but what this bill would do
would basically require the oplc to have
a specific individual not an executive
director but someone who could handle
customer service um obviously there have
been as things have sort of changed a
little bit sometimes in in uh rules and
statute um lenses have a number of
questions that they're looking um for
the real estate for the Real Estate
Commission oplc to answer in the past
maybe a year ago uh and I can vouch that
this was the case uh you might call over
the oplc and you would be on hold for 20
minutes or so um that has improved uh
and uh we have had lot of conversations
and director Courtney has uh always been
available to speak with the association
about some of our concerns uh and has
worked with us uh to try and resolve
some of these issues um so this bill
does not um appropriate any General
Revenue funds for these positions so it
would require either a transfer of
existing U Personnel into these
positions or as we potentially had
envisioned um it may require a border
commission to fund in essence through
fees since that's where oplc gets its
Revenue most of its revenue from so in
the conversation ations and in fact
during the Senate uh discussions as well
um we had suggested a potential
Amendment um that I'm happy to
distribute here and we also had rified
the oplc um and I don't want to speak
for them but I think they were okay with
it um where it basically Alters language
a little bit where it says that the oplc
with those boards over 7,000 shall
consult with the boards and commissions
and then may assign a dedicated customer
service administrator with the idea
being that maybe not all boards or
commissions would want to see uh
potentially fees increase in order to
guarantee that there was a a customer
service individual specifically assigned
to that U to that board of commission um
so and and it also makes it clear that
if that's the case that individual could
in fact oversee more than just one Board
of commission they might have two or
three um so I'm happy to distribute that
if there's interest in that uh and then
I will let Joanie finish up
um so in paragraph two uh the addition
of 7A um discussing post Licensing in
2018 um legislation uh s SP
461 was sponsored by Senator Carson and
it would alter continuing education in a
way that um during the initial period of
a lensey that first two years they would
take 12 specific courses um that would
really help them be better Realtors um
things about contracts and and um
closings and that type of thing um not
fluff classes um the intent was to make
sure that they had those basic skills
and um the uh the Real Estate Commission
pregated that rule and approved the
courses that would be um that would be
required for that first initial um
licensing um it went into effect in
2022 2022 and the oplc um late in the
year um said that they didn't understand
the post licensing what that meant it
wasn't in the statute um and so this um
legislation this piece this change will
Define that post licensing that 2year um
period after their before their fish for
their um initial
renewal um in section three this has to
do with um inactive status so in um when
House Bill 2 was passed last year we
believe it was this was inadvertently um
deleted of what constitutes inactive
status um in real real estate is
uniquely real estate is likely unique
among professions in AOW owing for an
inactive licens status um hb2
transferred various statute authorities
to oplc in RSA 310 however the statute
makes no mention of inactive status
we've discussed this with oplc and we
would defer to them how with any of
their new
enforcement um the removal of this
statute creates a number of problems
which include allowing a lensey to be
compensated for activities they are
involved in prior to going
inactive and then section four has to do
with
um the uh I guess added the commission
may approve prepar Preparatory
continuing and instructor education
programs of study with a single
application so section four allows for
the oplc to approve CES and other
courses
there had been issues where the oplc did
not feel comfortable um approving these
courses and pass them on to the Real
Estate Commission the Real Estate
Commission in some cases it was is too
large and they didn't feel that they
were um they had the material to do this
so they were unable to to handle that
responsibility um it led to no courses
being approved for about six months you
can see the the problem with that oplc
um uh ultimately issued an order
allowing them to review the courses um
this section simply puts that Authority
into statute the language also allows
for the courses and the instructor
approvals to occur with a single
application as opposed to having to
submit the the course and the the um
instructor
separately great thank you for your
testimony representative l
thank you um so in this last part if I
understood you correctly which I may not
have um I think you said that the
commission didn't feel that it could
approve the uh courses or did I
misunderstand that and if the if that's
true then uh what is adding language
saying that they may approve it actually
going to
do so um this issue occurred I don't
know we're about a year out now um where
there was uh oplc felt the existing
statutory language there was some
questions whether or not they could
approve courses or that was a
responsibility solely in the hands of
the real estate commission um the real
estate Commissioners have indicated that
that's was Way Beyond their ability to
review these some of these course
applications are 100 pages long um and
they felt that they did not have the
requisite skills in order to do that I
think that this issue largely has been
resolved um and the oplc now has taken
on some responsibility in working with
the Real Estate Commission in order to
approve those courses um since this bill
was first this this bill was introduced
so um you're correct I think that when
it says may at least it gives them the
opportunity to assist um but I think
right now things are kind of working
reasonably well in terms of the approval
of courses followup follow up so is
there language and I know I'm just
looking at part of it here but is there
Lang language that gives the authority
to oplc does the oplc have authority to
do it I'm going to defer to director
Courtney to answer how they're working
that currently and
then well it's actually a a question on
another part and that's I you may have
said it and I think I may have missed it
but on the post licensing where is that
referred to doesn't appear to be in
statute is that in rules or so no um
there is it's um in RSA
3318 to I believe currently uh no it
does it appears in both rules and
statute so this was a bill uh that was
introduced by Senator Carson uh in 2018
that passed that set up the post
licensing requirement uh and I think
that the office of Professional
Licensing felt that the definition of
post-licensing was not sufficient in
order to continue to enforce so the
intent here is to provide that
definition so that that post-licensing
requirement can happen um I will mention
that we would suggest another amendment
uh to the bill and just change February
1st 2020 to February 1st
2024 um and the reason for that is if we
put in 2020 then people who are
currently um had initially uh been
approved for a real estate license would
now suddenly potentially with very
little notice have to take different
continuing education courses than what
they may have been taken over the past
two years so we'd like it move sort of
moving forward so only someone who
becomes a leny after February of 2024
would be subject to this follow up
followup so I I searched through all of
331a I didn't see any reference to post
or post licensing so if you send that
and um well what's in statute and all
and then um any reference to the rules
you're talking about sure
absolutely thank you represent schm
thank you Mr chairman um couple of
questions uh the reference in the uh
analysis
indicates
a um
qualification uh of the for such um a
step forward to have a any agency board
commission which exceeds 7,000 lenses
how many licenses do you
have I I think that there are I think
there are about and I will again defer
to direct corn I think there are about
10,000 real estate licenses in the state
currently okay that was my belief but uh
I only saw 7,000 here so I thought but
it exceeds I think the the language says
that if a border commission has more
then exceeds I understand but but I I I
was figuring there were probably were
more like 10,000 so I was wondering they
must be somebody else they trying to
pick off with the number
7,000 uh so second question uh I'm sorry
I your colleague who's the president uh
was introduced uh as if everybody on
this committee had functioning hearing
that would disqualify me immediately uh
so could you please say your name again
Joanie McIntyre McIntyre Ah that's a
name I can even spell thank you and j o
n i j o a n i e oh j o n i e and
McIntyre is t i r
e unless you spell it different than all
the other mcintyres I know how to spell
it okay thank you very
much representative
Brown uh thank you Mr chair and thanks
for being here taking my
question so the what is the um value for
a
person to extend their license as
opposed to uh to to put it on an active
status it sounds like they still have to
take uh they have to renew the license
and still do the
cus is it just that this will save them
money for assurity bond or maintaining a
place of business is that the is that
the basic plus to this for those people
so those people only have to take one of
the courses they only have to take the
core course
and and then when they want to
reactivate they have to have all the
other courses but if they were to go
inactive for four years they would just
have to take the one core course each
okay each buing thank you you're
welcome sorry any other questions yep
representative
G so I'm I'm
uh someone who likes to have statues
that
are
solid and when you have May in a statue
what it that means like nothing to me
right the commission may approve you're
either going to or you're not and I
don't know I mean someone's going to own
that or someone's not going to own it to
me just this is a statement that has no
value in statute because it's too
vague do you have comments on
that so again I will defer to director
Courtney in terms of um the statutory
Authority that they're using right now
um I guess the only intent here was
prior to the oplc said they had no
Authority uh to assist or um to approve
continuing education so the intent was
to at least give them the opportunity uh
to do so if both the real estate
commission and the oplc felt it was
worthy that was the intent at least
whether not meets that intent I don't
any other questions representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman so earlier
on Bob you were talking about uh the the
uh the examination and if
the the U date of uh the statute
proposed statute come going into effect
could mess up uh somebody who got uh
their license at that particular
particular moment uh we find is those of
us who've been on this committee for a
while that there's a lot of stuff in the
statute that um in my opinion is a
potential landmine because addresses and
so forth uh that are in
statute if that address is no longer
accurate now the statute has to be
changed in order to uh to have it be
correct um wouldn't it be better to have
these detail of the of the license exam
qualify qualifying exam wouldn't that be
better to be something that the the
board would have the authority to change
and uh and it should actually be in
rules yeah I mean I I think a lot of
that is already in existing statutory uh
rules as well as the uh real estate
which is rea the Reas um in in the RS so
so I think a lot of that stuff's already
there but I'm happy to have a
conversation with you about um other
issues that you feel might be better off
putting in though okay thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony director Courtney you were
nodding your head a lot would you like
to testify on this
good afternoon Lindsay Courtney
executive director office rationalizes
Insurance
certification
um I guess I would start by saying that
I think that the Genesis of this bill
this conversation started um probably
over a year and a half ago and I just
want to commend the
association um we've enjoyed a very
collaborative working relationship um
and I think that uh we could certainly
um continue to work on some language uh
that um that we can come to an agreement
on there are there have been some some
changes since this bill was
introduced um that I think uh would
require um perhaps some modification to
the to the current language I'll start
with section four and I just want to
give the committee a little bit of a
overview of what was happening at the
time this issue came about that prompted
the
bill so about a year and a half ago um
prior to to House Bill 655 House Bill 2
uh House Bill 409 passing that gave the
office the authority to issue
licenses um we our boards were the
subject of several performance audits
Dental Board um mental health uh there
were a couple prior to that which made
clear that unless there was statutory
Authority um to have the office approve
licenses that all of the license
applications are supposed to be approved
by the respective
boards and then subsequently around that
same time we had staff members for the
Real Estate Commission leave which gave
us an opportunity to kind of look into
what's been going on for many years and
what had been going on for many years is
that staff had been evaluating approving
um programs uh
instructors and that approval did not
line up with the statutes or the rules
so so uh um one of our goals of our
strategic plan is to ensure that we are
complying with our statutes and rules so
I personally took a look at the issue
and quickly determined that um there was
a statutory requirement for the
commission at the time to accredit real
estate courses now because approval is
required that is tantamount to a license
under New Hampshire law there's also a
statutory requirement for the commission
to accredit instructors again it's tant
amount to a license under New Hampshire
law so essentially the commission is
required to license both courses and
instructors uh the rules are continue to
be a total mess in terms of the
requirements between instructors and
courses are
conflated um and the application and
approval process that had been done by
staff were also conflated so our records
uh did not accurately ref reflex whether
an instructor had been issued an
instructor license and a course had been
approved um it wasn't uh it wasn't in
compliance with the law at the same time
we didn't have statutory authority to
approve these courses or deny them so we
said to the commission this is your
statutory responsibility you have to do
that um as previously noted they were
concerned about the
bandwidth subsequently this legislature
passed House Bill 2 655 409 that gave us
that Authority so we are now um
approving the courses we are also
approving
instructors based on the PLC rules um as
well as any additional requirements set
forth by the commission So currently we
are issuing both instructor licenses and
we are approving courses now from a
policy consideration I'm not taking a
position on whether you need a license
instructors I do want to raise that
question because I don't what value
added there is in licensing the
instructors if you're also approving the
course so that's something that I think
we need to consider and I think the past
history represents that the commission
and commission staff had conflated the
two and had really become one process if
it is intended to be one process we
probably just need to repeal the
requirement that we license instructors
separately but again I don't take a
position on that from a policy
standpoint I don't think the current
language in section 4 would actually
make it any clearer um it would actually
arguably confuse it further because it
says the commission may approve
Preparatory courses and Contin education
courses and I think I I don't want to
speak for the association but I do know
that the commission and the office agree
that the office should be approving
these courses they don't have the
bandwidth and um and really the
requirement should be objective and we
should be able to do that so I think by
just removing um that section it should
it should be fine the other issue is the
single application issue if they are two
separate licenses which under New
Hampshire law they currently are um we
would need we would need um we would
need to capture that information
separately um and the reason for that is
you're going to have different
instructors on different approved on
different courses and the way we uh
Implement that from a technological
standpoint we wouldn't be able to
separate that now again though I think
that the inclusion of that language in
this bill just represents that there's
been a historic practice of Just
conflating The Two and maybe we need to
uh work on whether or not we should be
doing it that way statutorily um so all
that's to say is that's the history of
that I think it's moving um it's working
now um in light of uh what ooks did last
year um and we can certainly work with
the association and the commission on
some additional language as necessary
the office doesn't take a position on
inactive status um we some of our boards
have inactive status some don't some
have inactive status that are required
to renew some don't um we are capable of
implementing that in either
fashion with respect to section two the
post licensing course so this again goes
back to our um adherence or attempts to
adhere to the statutes and the rules so
so the Real Estate Commission rules like
many of our board rules are not the best
and in the current rules they use
postlicensing and electives
interchangeably so it's not clear based
on our review of the rules um that
postlicensing actually refers to that
first uh renewal
cycle um I think that is the reason why
this definition would provide that
Clarity and we don't take a position on
that we're we we're happy to implement
it um but uh the reason we haven't been
able to implement it is because the
current requirement that essentially
conflates postlicensing period with
electives conflicts with the statute and
we can't have a rule that conflicts with
with with the statute so by adding that
definition I think it would certainly
provide the clarity needed and we can
Implement um we can Implement what the
commission would like to do which is to
create uh four separate categories of
requirements for that first renewal
cycle so lastly the other the the
remaining issue is about the um section
one and I I know that the association Mr
Quinn I referenced an amendment um
we I'm sure we can find um an agreement
and it's probably that language that I
haven't re-reviewed but we did agree to
other language that we we could work uh
we could work together
on um my concern primarily with section
one is that the boards are currently
already not meeting their costs so as
you see on the handout that I provided
to you um there are I've actually
separated nursing with nursing
assistants based on the conversations
that we've had in the past and the
potential goal of getting nursing
assistance funded through a different
mechanism but there are currently 7
boards that are um that have over 7,000
lenses we recently did a um an analysis
of where we think they will be in FY 26
based on the current funding that we
receive from the boards as well as
assuming that we don't have any
additional
Appropriations so the only boards that
are currently meeting their costs are
Engineers Medicine and
Pharmacy um the office through the next
budget session is going to have to uh
work with the boards and we are
currently working with the boards
they've all received a letter um as to
whether we're going to cut expenses or
increase Revenue so if we are required
to add additional staff obviously that
just would um lead to a potential uh
increase in the deficit um and we have
other boards that are essentially
subsidizing certain boards so that's our
primary
concern the other concern is that what
we're trying to do
and I fully recognize that particularly
at the time that this bill um was
introduced that the office was
particularly challenged by the volume of
calls um by a lack you know the probably
an inefficient way of managing our call
volume um um we certainly had some
concerns with staff responding to com to
constituent inquiries in a timely
fashion I do think that not I think we
have made a concered effort to improve
that and I think the ICS show that on
average um our weight time is fairly
minimal we already have three dedicated
staff licensing staff that support the
real estate commission and the Real
Estate Commission only and we have a
shared board administrator who's
responsible for being the liaison and
then our first tier calls are answered
by the customer service unit if they're
not able to answer the question they're
passed on to licensing as tier two so
the concern with having one dedicated
person to answer the phones and respond
to inquiries that I'm always concerned
about as a single point of failure when
I first joined the office we had single
points of failure everywhere um we
didn't even know what phone numbers we
had staff would leave and we had
voicemails that apparently were full
nobody knew that we had those voicemails
there were old numbers that had been
assigned to other people there were
checks in the drawers there were emails
that nobody could access there was
information hoarding going going on all
over the place this is why it's taken me
5 years to even get to the point where
we can look at the Real Estate
Commission um course issues so I'm
always a little hesitant to say that
there should be one person
responsible um for uh for this
particular function um because Anything
Could Happen they could go out uh and
they could get hit by a bus they could
win the lottery and we have no idea what
you know what's been going on what's
been communicated so I think we need to
have systems in the office and the
system that we currently have is that we
have an intake procedure we don't have
the ability to leave voicemails on our
main
line um we have a triage system we have
a logging system calls get transferred
that gets logged so we have the ability
to pull metrics like this
so I think that the association has
raised a valid concern and I think that
we are working hard to address their leg
very legitimate
concerns I don't know that I want to I
think we should legislate a solution
because I think that there may be other
solutions that we should continue to
look at outside of the statutory process
that said um the amendment that Mr Quinn
passed around that's something that we
could certainly live with if you know we
could make it work um it basically would
require us to consult with the boards
which we are already required to do with
respect to funding and if you know they
so desire a particular position um then
then that's something we can certainly
live with the other final piece that
I'll just leave you with is that um
people are not uh banging down the the
doors at the state to get a job here um
this is very different from when I first
started in 2019 where we could hire
people so even assuming we had such
positions it's not a guarantee that we
could fill them and it's not a guarantee
that we could fill them at um with
qualified applicants so I think
regardless of what we do um this year
the office is committed to having other
Solutions um in place to ensure that we
are improving customer service so thatd
be Happ to answer any questions thank
you representative Gera and
theas thanks I'm glad you qualified that
last statement because I'm I'm sort of
in the same boat that you you are um I
think that the whole purpose of the
changes that we made in oplc was to try
to manage the cost of the organization
and I understand that when you first
start something different it you know
can be challenging so I I don't I agree
with the 7,000 people putting somebody
to to handle that that is not something
that right now I'm I have the stomach to
do right um number two
um I would like more information on how
you
calculated the projected Revenue versus
cost ratio for these
because um that can be I mean I can see
you could do this many many different
ways so is that information you could
share with us yes so I personally did
the calculations it took me about a
month and a half um it's like painting
your house you think it's going to take
a day and it doesn't um I have two
spreadsheets uh one one cuz there's two
proposed cost allocation models um this
is based on the model that we currently
use and that's an allocation based on
license C and then I have so yes I can
certainly sit down with you they're very
lengthy spreadsheets um basically we
were able to get down into the
nitty-gritty and B basically able to
allocate costs of personnel which is our
highest expense by far based on uh
projected usage um which is determined
by basically an average past usage so
essentially the boards that are using uh
investigators are the boards that are
paying for that peretta portion of
investigator costs boards that don't use
investigators are not contributing to
that cost whereas previously we kind of
lumped all of those costs together and
so I think it's a more accurate picture
of what the boards are using in terms of
resources um than we've been able to do
in the past
thank
you um so this is a little more general
question seeing this uh projected p
ratio for these licenses that raises the
question for me is um are are you at
risk of of not meeting the requirement
of oplc being
self-funding so I would
say not this fiscal year so the the
the 12% increase particularly with wages
last year um is a challenge for the
office uh historically we've had a
lapse um
and this body changed that so we don't
lapse money and so we did have some roll
over last year and so we are meaning our
cost this year but we're eating into
that rollover so it's clear that we're
not bringing in sufficient Revenue um on
a yearly basis to continue to uh manage
to to pay for all of these appropriated
expenses and part of that has to do with
the fact that many boards and this is
contained in the letters that I sent to
the boards over the last month is that
many boards haven't raised their fees in
20 years and so um that coupled with
inflation coupled with increased costs
just of doing business Personnel costs
are by far largest
expense um that's challenge so we're
going to have to make some decisions and
um the decisions are obviously decrease
expenditures or Inc increase
Appropriations and I think it may be a
combination of both um cosmetology for
example is at what 28% they've been
around that for years because they have
uh only charged their lenses $50 or $40
for 2 years nobody pays that you know
you've got the Physicians paying $350
and they've been paying that for years
and so when you and and barbering uses a
significant amount of
resources so I think that we're going to
have to have some hard conversations
with these boards over the next couple
months as to you know what would you
like to
do okay and uh this is to the chair or
or Madam not currently the chair is this
go into licensing subcommittee
oh let's talk afterwards certainly thank
you representative
goalie thank you Mr chair and one quick
question as you were talking earlier
about hiring individuals and trying to
get people in could you tell me uh where
you are on vacancy rate for those
answering theil emails and the phone
calls or if they're fully filled so we
just fully staffed that Customer Service
Unit uh it's only five people um but for
a while we had only filled two of the
positions it's a position that's very
difficult to fill because you're
answering phones all day um so what we
did is we required every person in the
office including myself to take uh a
certain segment of time on a weekly
basis and answer phone calls that's how
we were able to get down the phone calls
um we were just able to remove the staff
who aren't assigned to CSU from that
call unit um just this week and I will
be monitoring to make sure that the call
volume is still low or the the weight
times are still
low anyone else yes representative
go but do I remember the question now
okay yes I do
so my question is given the time crunch
for all of
this if you talked if I if I heard you
correctly you talked about there was
some
conflicting um statutes currently that
complicate matters for this commission
is that correct and the
office so I think section four would
would um confuse things further I think
at the time that it was
drafted it was not clear maybe we didn't
have that Authority yet under 655 or 409
but now we do so I don't think we need
section four
um so follow up follow up so my question
was I I I heard that I was correct in
understanding there's already some
conflictual stuff my question is if we
do not pass this does it make matters
worse or better
I think you would I think that and I I
don't take a position but I think
there's
a articulated need on the
inactive piece um that makes sense to me
and so I think I would would think you
would need to move something forward in
order to make that happen um and I think
postlicensing the definition as well now
I think the Real Estate Commission has
the authority to do that in rule um and
so we're we're B basically inserting a
statutory definition to shore up their
rules when in reality they could just
redo the rules um but practically that's
always a challenge with some of our with
with regulatory
boards okay thank you representative
grto so a possible
solution would be to take that inactive
piece and add it to something else so we
we that's not the where the fiscal note
comes in right the fiscal note comes in
because uh of the requirement as worded
that we have dedicated staff right yes
correct so if we okay so that's one way
of handling of getting that across the
Finish Line without taking the rest of
the bill with
us well I what I don't want to do is
sorry any other any other questions
thank you director appreciate your time
did anybody else wish to testify on S SP
480 seeing no one I will close a public
hearing on S SP 480 I will open up the
public hearing on SB
372 and uh welcome the very patient
Senator
Murphy thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity my name is
Senator Murphy I represent the people of
gtown hookit candy Raymond and
Manchester's First
Ward one of the strengths of our
legislature is that we are not paid
$75,000 to be here as much as that might
be we all have had careers in the past
or have careers now and one of my
earlier careers was that I spent a year
as a uh as electrician's Apprentice I
spent a year crawling around ceilings
and wiring up light fixtures and wiring
um outlets and you know panels and all
the things electricians do before I
decided that that was not the career for
me I was one of four apprentices under a
master electrician when I was um in
training and
when I learned to my surprise uh that we
have a maximum number of apprentice
plumbers
per master of one a ratio of one to
one and I was very surprised because we
all know there's a big problem with
building in New Hampshire there's a it's
Builders are finding it very challenging
to get enough workers to build their uh
the homes and we have a housing crisis
in the state we all know that there's a
number of factors why that's the case
but a lack of talent and a lack of
people in the trades is a big part of
that so anything we can do to alleviate
that bottleneck I think is something
that we need to take a strong look at so
this bill was put in and passed because
we in the Senate believe that we can
double the number of apprentices going
to the process and that would be a a
good thing to do a strong step to take
um
the the bill hearing we had in the
Senate uh revealed that this was
actually a Federal Regulation there was
a federal training program that we we
could possibly be at risk of losing and
so that's why the bill was uh changed to
make the apprenticeship program optional
if The Apprentice is registered in the
federal program then it would have to
comply with the Department of Labor
which again does still require that one:
one ratio that's a federal requirement
not every state is in that program but
we happen to be there um so the person
doing the hiring the employer can choose
to uh use the registered apprentices
with Department of Labor or can choose
simply to hire people and keep them
outside of that program um I did pass
out an amendment because after passage
um we heard a concern that the language
in the bill as passed
was possibly open to uh reading it two
different ways and so all this amendment
does and I would hope you would pass it
um is to clear up exactly what the
initial bill what was meant to do
clarify that um that a master plumber
could have no more than two par liy not
a minimum of two which is the concern so
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much thank you
very much any questions for the
senator seeing none Senator thank you
very much thank you very
much would anybody else like to testify
on SP
372 seeing no one I'll close the public
hearing on SB 372 and we'll March right
into SB 487 and open the public heing on
that and
welcome Senator
Carson good afternoon Mr chairman and
good afternoon members of the House Edna
committee for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of Auburn London
Derry and Hudson and I have today for
your consideration Senate Bill 487
relative to the division of Personnel in
the department of administrative
Services I would like to uh just point
out the bill basically does three things
it creates a new chapter for the
Personnel appeals board it repeals six
statutes related to the Department of
administrative Services Division and the
bill is a request from the Department of
administrative
Services um just a little background
about the administrative Appeals board
ad hears appeals from state employees
who believe an application of the New
Hampshire Personnel rules have been
taken wrongly against them most often
these cases are appeals of disciplinary
actions such as letters of warning or
termination from state employee
currently the board is administratively
attached to the division of personnel
within administrative Services it shares
administrative staff who are employed
and supervised by the division of
personnel the board's operating expenses
are also managed by the division of
personnel at times the administrative
attachment with the division of
personnel can cause a conflict of
interest by managing uh the board
operations but more importantly on
decisions the boards the board makes in
appeals of employees all question all
cases question the decisions made by
direct employees and
ultimately the division of personnel
it's not on common for the director of
the division of personnel or even the
commissioner of the Department of
administrative services to be mentioned
in disciplinary documents that come in
front of the board that means the
director of personnel or the
commissioner of the department could be
Witnesses before the
board given their role in administering
the board's budget and staff the
potential conflict of interest is
apparent Senate Bill 487 dissolves the
the existing administrative
attachment to the division of personnel
and reorganizes the Personnel appeals
board as a full an entity fully
independent from the division of
personnel as well as other state
agencies um sen 487 does have a fiscal
impact of approximately
$253,000 in
2025 and
35,000 in
2026 it also establishes a fund for
basic operating expensive part-time
Staffing parking office space equipment
and supplies um at this point Mr
chairman I will uh conclude my testimony
and someone from the Department is here
to go into detail um we did have a very
uh good public hearing we did have some
conflicts that uh the parties were able
to get together and resolve so the bill
that you see as amended by the Senate
really speaks to a compromise between
state employees labor attorneys and the
department of administrative services so
thank you all very much for your time
this afternoon I appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you and again
I'd ask you to hold your questions
because the gentleman from the
Department of administrative Services is
here but I see a couple people want to
try to ask questions and I will try to
answer them if I can yes represent I'm
just gonna point to this gentleman
sitting here uh just just briefly you
said that um something about it being
independent but it's in uh 273 which is
under labor so is it actually going to
be under the the under the Department of
Labor is that the plan um again
representative he's shaking his head I
think he can answer that question all
I'll come to the Senator's defense and
just wait until the gentleman from the
labor is here is it is it something
specifically for her or no oh
okay no I just wanted to make the
committee members aware that uh you
should be looking at the version with
the Senate Amendment
1177 the bill that was originally in
your packets did not include the
amendment thank you
representative thank you Senator thank
you very much Mr chairman uh I hope all
of you have a good afternoon this is the
last bill so you as
well I need a pink
card you can get it to me afterwards if
you want to just I'll need one and if
you just want to introduce yourself
that's fine for
now good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee appreciate you taking a
time today in considering this bill my
name is m MAV George I'm the deputy
director of personnel at the department
of administrative services and as
Senator Carson said first of all I'd
like to thank Senator Carson for
sponsoring this bill um it's been an
effort to get this across the finish
line but we appreciate the collaborative
approach we've had with both the
president or chair of the Personnel
appeals board and the unions we all
worked uh collaboratively on this
amendment to uh get it to where it is
today and we all agree that the current
amended version of the bill is um a
version that we can live with at this
time and and we were all doing so in the
spirit of the ultimate goal of the bill
which is to get the Personnel appeals
board uh separated and truly independent
that being said uh the Department
administrative services and the unions
did have some uh substantive things that
they would like to reserve the right to
uh take up at maybe at a future
legislative session but we felt that the
time wasn't right with this bill to
necessarily Advance those issues at this
time be happy to take any questions at
any m MERS of the committee might have
regarding this bill representative
leas um first my uh question from before
and that this is in the part of Statute
under the uh uh Department of Labor and
is it part of the Department of Labor or
what does independent mean who who they
who's responsible for it sure they will
not be part of the Department of Labor
it it sits very similar to like the
Personnel not Personnel the uh Public
Employee labors relation board which is
another truly independent entity in the
state they don't they're not
administratively attached or affiliated
with any other state agency and if this
bill were to pass the Personnel appeals
board would operate very similarly it's
just where it lands in the structure of
the chapter laws follow up follow up so
are they basically I mean under the
governor directly is that either one of
those is that uh right they would just
be like any other state agency and some
of them are much smaller than others
some state agencies are very small and
this would just be like another example
of that reporting directly up and
hopefully one more follow up if I could
okay so um other than what what it sits
under is the structure of this basically
the same as the existing board or is
there some some changes are there some
changes as far as the makeup of the
board how it operates right yeah the
majority of the language is almost
identical to the current version of the
Personnel appeals board as far as how it
sits deal only difference is right now
it sits in the chapter laws for the
Department administrative services this
would take it out of that that's why it
repeals a number of sections of the
current law and sticks it in its own
section gives it its own operating
budget and staff that's really the main
difference okay thank you representative
welcome that your question represent
Brown thank you Mr chair uh thanks for
taking my question um on line
10 it says at least one member shall be
an attorney licensed to practice in the
state of New
Hampshire and an additional requirements
experience in the conduct of
adjudicative hearings and decision
writing on line 16 it says both the
chairperson and vice chairperson shall
be attorneys is there an inconsistency
there so should it say there should be
two attorneys or is it
that is it that that first attorney has
to be experienced in adjudicative
hearings and decision writing
I see what you're saying yeah
representative that that's a fair point
I think that's something that could be
addressed pretty easily and make the
requirement uh that it be at least two
to make it consistent thank
you I suppose at least one is
potentially two
but yeah any other questions y could be
a way to read it consistently the two
but
yeah you helped me out last week I'm
just
uh I see no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony sure thank
you very much did anybody else wish to
speak on S SP 487 director are you
speaking on this one I didn't think so
it didn't seem like your sort of thing
having said that I will close the public
hearing on S SP 487 and we made it you
guys are released for the
day I don't know if we're executing
anything for
um didn't we have a time set aside
tomorrow if we had to follow up didn't
get through the the agenda today
okay oh okay thank you thank you my
apolog thank you thank you thank you so
Senate Bill 134 does somebody have a
motion
a to
pass okay representative Schmidt moves
all to
pass and representative gold second did
you wish to speak to your motion I do
thank you madam chair
so um I was astonished by the testimony
we heard on this
bill and crestfallen to realize that it
could be possible in this state
to have police officers who faced
gunfire and were not merely facing
gunfire but were shot multiple
times and were
miraculously not killed on the
spot and if we can put
$100,000 on the line for fallen
firefighters or police off
officers
um and
not something similar
for uh people who are shot but survive
or run over by vehicles and survive then
I think that we ought to do what this
bill I don't know whether the bill is
any good in terms of its mechanics but
you guys are going to tell me
that thank you representative gold do
you wish to speak to your second thank
you madam chair I I agree with
everything my colleague said and I'll
just add uh with all of the concerns we
all hear and we all share about PTSD and
our First Responders all I needed to
hear was our statute State they are
worth more dead than
alive represent blackis I'm certainly
not opposed to this and I support what
it's trying to do I just feel more
comfortable voting for it not saying I
won't if I had some kind of a realistic
fiscal note I'm and the reason I'm
concerned is the existing one is so
large and looking at the changes it's
not clear to me why it would be
dramatically
less I don't know I'd like to comment on
that because I was listening to the to
Mr Carlin and the other people speaking
about the cost apparently when they did
the first
estimate they were incredibly
conservative on how many people this
would apply to and they were also
working from the first version of the
bill which had a lot of factors that
this one doesn't at the moment the cost
is some reprogramming at the retirement
system of
course the difference between their
current pension and
$75,000 for the two individuals who have
been identified plus $11,000 a month
for medical uh benefits so
approximately it may be as much as
$100,000 a year for each of two people
and considering the limitations on what
kind of
a an event would allow somebody to
qualify for this I can't think that it's
going to be a I mean they must have been
assuming that vast numbers of police
officers are going to get shot so and
since we don't think that's the case we
pray that's not the case it's it can't
be that as much as is in the fiscal note
the fiscal notes also based on the
unamended bill which was different have
you
yes very quickly so when this when the
original bill came in with regard to um
$100,000 for dead firefighters of police
officers we initially looked at the
funding mechanism Diane you'll remember
um and it was you know we decided that
the insurance policy was going to be
more expensive to than just paying for
it out of the general fund and we
changed it to funding through out of the
general fund and it's it's never the
issue has never been raised again
representative
Shu thank you madam chair uh I would
just point out that um we are all aware
of the law enforcement
memorial uh out in front of this
building and most officers that are
injured in this manner are no longer
with us so I think we owe it to those
that do happen to survive to do this for
them repres laus yeah so and I'm not
arguing against that um I just if I'm
going to vote for it I want to feel a
little comfortable about this one is so
they what we're thinking is maybe a
couple hundred, and hopefully not much
in the future um would just be out of
the retirement system um what isn't
clear to me is where does the money for
the medical insurance part come from is
that general f that's also from the
retirement system it's they have a
medical uh medical subsidy that's
limited to a small number of people okay
all right thank you
represent goalie thank you madam chair
and that medical subsidy I believe is
tied to the um normal costs when they
figure it in going forward y um but if I
may um I just specifically want to thank
um Mr dhy and Mr Lewis for their
services that they provided being from
Manchester and working 32 and half years
on the fire department side by side um I
appreciate it and thank you very much
and thank you for bringing this forward
I hope it helps and it goes
forward I'd like to to say that we
should look very hard at why Timeout on
workers compensation doesn't count
toward one's pension because if you're
injured or hurt on the job for any
reason you you you can't work I mean and
it should be creditable and I think
that's something to look into for next
year
anyone else repr Simon I was just going
to say I agree with that Madam chair I
was hoping we were under too um too much
of a time crunch but I was hoping to be
able to fit that into this this one but
uh yeah we'll look at it for next
year okay anyone
else all right in that case a motion is
ought to pass by representative
Schmidt cler can call the RO
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representive Dolan yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu absolutely representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes 16 y z nay
all right I think it's this should not
be on consent
representative Schmidt I would like your
committee report at your very earliest
convenience I'll get right on it thank
you
okay um Senate Bill 480 is the next
early
Bill
and as mentioned okay thank you thank
you um I
had while I was was watching the
watching you guys work the real estate
board s or the the association suggested
that we delete sections one and four
which are
the the Troublesome
parts and simply pass sections two and
three which they need to as soon as
possible um one one addition to that is
there was a comment I think they made
about the date in section 2 moving it
from 2020 to 2024 so we don't change the
requirements underneath people at least
that was my
understanding
okay the the post licensing is I believe
a reference to a a some language in the
rule that allows the board to
specify different
training continuing education
requirements for new new uh real estate
agents that don't apply to more senior
people so in their first year they have
specific training
requirements and so is there any reason
for it to be earlier than
24 a little fuzzy on that I don't think
so yeah that's what they asked for
doesn't mean that right so represent
so if we have an amendment to this bill
that only includes that section does
that remove it from an early bill
because there's no fiscal note now no no
no it's if it's an early bill it's an
early Bill even if you change it into a
study committee I think the issue is
that we we can't guarantee that the
house will accept the amendment and so
we can't be sure it won't have a big
fiscal note oh I mean we can assume but
we can't guarantee it technically also
the system is not set up for that kind
of flexibility it once an early Bill
always an early
bill but we're saying that we only want
to have section two and three and three
right and that's what the amendment
would would recognize correct correct
and change the date on line 13 right and
so could we have an amendment and vote
on this next Tuesday certainly
okay we will take care of that and
unless there is some objection to or
other discussion or comments on
this no and if it's okay with the with
the chair I have to go to o oh I think
they're going to still be open I have to
go to OLS about something else so I can
take this down with me if you'd like
you'd like to I'm more than welcome my
only my only non- uh comment is I'm not
amused by the Senate heing drunk over
the wall it I am not amused by Senate
the Senate sending us drunk either we
will have to deal with it okay so Senate
Bill 480 we will we have an amendment
pending and we'll vote on it on Tuesday
and just to be clear it's an amendment
that in that is really relates to
section two and three only right with a
one change in date okay all right Senate
Bill
487 division of
personnel does someone have a
motion um move out of pass on Senate
Bill
487 all right I'll
second wish to speak to it sure I think
that for um to address the conflicts
between the appeals board sitting inside
the um the
um uh agency board this bill would
address that and it seems to have been
um a collaborative effort and I think
the um the committee should pass
it and um in response to my second I'd
like to say that this this
uh bill as amended does have very good
transition language it says that the
current members are to stay there unless
um according to the to the current law
we don't have to reappoint the whole
board and it and uh Das will help them
to get their office set up and so forth
do we need to address the conflict that
representative Brown raised about the
number of attorneys on the two lines
that's an existing law I personally
think they've got three
attorneys
um he he noted at least at least well
one me at least one member Labor
Relations or Personnel professional at
least one shall be employed at public
personnel and at least one member is an
attorney experienced of the conduct of
adjudicative hearings and decision
writing and the chair and the vice chair
shall be
attorneys one of whom could be that
other attorney all right
but it sounds like there's two attorney
at least two attorneys two uh labor
people and one person who might be
either
I just the gentleman from Personnel just
indicated that he would be okay with
fixing that agre to make it clearer I
just thought I'd raise it okay well I um
I think that's current statute and I'm
not and I don't know what it should
say well that like I said the the
testimony from the gentleman from
Personnel said that that that was a
little conflict that could need fixing
so he also said agreed that at Le at
least one means could mean two yeah yeah
okay R laus yeah just uh do you do you
or anyone have any idea why the cost is
going from 72 72,000 to 356,000 for
running the board I'm just
curious
um probably because the effective date
is 10 know 60 days after uh passage well
it's for each of the following three
years oh oh no it's the current budget
is 72,000 it goes to 356 right because
they are getting a separate Office
Independent people they're not stealing
people from the division of personnel
okay thank
you for their
staff representative
Schmid so I finally gave into the fact
that I can't hear worth a lick except
when you guys are talking and and uh so
I was out of the office out of the
committee room when this bill was heard
if everybody else is comfortable with
this B with this bill I'll stay and vote
Yes on it otherwise I don't think I
should vote on it but but if everybody
else is comfortable with this and think
sounds like it's a solid bill I'll stay
on vote for
it
okay anyone
else okay then the motion is off to pass
by representative groda
and the cler can call the RO
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Dolan clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
gr yes representative Schmidt I think
so representative goalie yes
representative sht yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitz Patrick
yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes 15 a0 a okay uh this is again is too
expensive to go on consent so we'll put
on the regular
calendar
[Music]
yes that's what I was about to come up
with we have to change we have to get a
new Amendment though we have to get a
new Amendment all right so it's a it's a
senate
Senate Amendment
unfortunately so
to yes please okay but does anyone have
any other comments on this on that on
senle 372 to go to to
apprentices okay if the plumber
wishes okay so we
will recess the exec on that to in order
to get a proper house type Amendment and
vote on it on
Tuesday all
right we are here on
Tuesday it will be in the Legislative
Office Building I think it's in this
room but I wouldn't swear to it we will
uh we can find it that going to be
notice with a revised Amendment or do we
not or revised notice we don't need that
we it will probably be revised but we'll
list the the two bills that we need
amendments for okay um does any how
about Senate Bill
600 that's I have serious reservations
about that bill okay I think that okay
well that was that was the other
question I had if it's if there are
questions that serious about it we'll
send it to subcommittee and let them at
least talk through the issues and and we
won't schedule this one for an exact on
Tuesday I think I think there's a few
problems one is the issue of uh
certified versus license should it be or
I think that's and then the number of
years there
was people want to change it so that
doesn't even sound workable he said it's
a a lot of turnover in that field uh and
it would be very unlikely you would have
a lot of people age we'll have questions
in subcommittee Toc I hear you I'm just
saying yeah okay it looks like it'll be
a lively subcommittee on that and I
don't know why the the board of
accountancy wants 30 months instead of
18 months to finish taking the
test since they didn't bother to show
up mad CH good luck dealing with that
one so recap um 600 Went to went to
subcommittee representative Gro is
getting an amendment to cut up Senate
Bill 480 represent ative G is getting an
amendment to adopt the Senate amendment
to 372 and the other two have been
passed okay thank you
all and I am closing the
meeting we'll see you Tuesday right yes
today Wednesday Today is Wednesday we'll
see you
Tuesday
um so the other
Okay so